e
here some administrative stuff needs to
be
done
e
on today's
agenda um I'm going to open the public
hearing on HB
um we're gonna represented Harrington to
thank you Mr chairman um representative
Michael Harrington I represent straford
district 18 and I'm presenting Bill HB
135 which is pretty simple bill it
basically codifies part of our state
Constitution Article 1 Section 12 uh
which is pretty clear about what it
says
um it says but no part of a man's
property shall be taken from him or
applied to public use without his
consent or that of his representative
body of people nor are the inhabitants
of this state controllable by any other
laws than those which we which they or
the representative body have given their
consent and this has to do with the
Wayfair decision having to do with sales
tax and in the way of a little history
um some time ago there was a movement by
sales tax states to they want to impose
the sales tax on non-sales tax states so
if someone from New Hampshire
sells a product to say Massachusetts or
New York or or South Dakota then that uh
company in New Hampshire would be
responsible for collecting and providing
that sales tax revenue to the state and
to put that in a little bit of
perspective the best estimate I've heard
so far is there's over 13,000 different
sales tax rates in this in the country
and that's because each state may have a
different one they have some have city
tax some don't
uh it varies on items I mean here's a
quirk to show that examples of how
strange some of these laws are if under
the Wayfare decision you would to sell a
um a charcoal grill to someone in
Massachusetts you would collect tax on
the grill but if you sold them a bag of
charcoal to go along with it you
wouldn't collect tax on the charcoal
because charcoal is called a fuel and
therefore it's exempt from sales tax um
another example from my friends in
Massachusetts they just announced
they're going to put sales tax on candy
now PR previously food was exempt from
the sales tax I imagine there'll be two
or three pages of definition of what
constitutes candy I mean is Baker's
chocolate that's going to used to make a
pie is that candy or is it only
chocolate that's going to go into
Hershey's bars so it's extremely
complicated I see of no way anyone can
keep up on this because they're subject
to change constantly you'd have to hire
an outside service in order to keep up
with these 13,000 plus different sales
tax rates so what happened is a while
ago a bunch of States decided there was
a decision called The Quill decision
which was made by the Supreme Court and
it said no if you don't have a physical
presence in that state the state cannot
collect sales tax from it and that was
how everything worked for quite some
time a bunch of States decided we didn't
want this we want to get sales tax from
everybody mostly because of the
increased business through the internet
and 20 States actually passed laws that
said we will collect taxes from other
states basically saying we're going to
to defy the quill decision and that
eventually made it up to the Supreme
Court and the Supreme Court being pushed
by former Justice Kennedy ruled 5 to
four to overturn that and came up with
the Wayfair decision now the Wayfair
decision is of course not quite as
simple as just saying well you have to
keep track of all 13,000 various sales
taxes because many of these states have
caveats in the law excuse me could you
hold on a second um would you mind going
out and talk roing out in the hall
okay many of these states have caveats
in the law the most common one is that
if you do not have over 200 shipments to
a particular state or you do not exceed
$100,000 you do not have to collect the
sales tax of course the problem comes
there is maybe you think well last year
I had 150 uh shipments to South Dakota
probably don't have to worry about
collecting the sales tax so I don't
November comes around and I go uhoh I
just hit 198 I can't go back and collect
all that sales tax from the orders that
I've already sent so the only thing I
can do is now stop selling my product to
any state with that uh limits coming
about so as you can see it's extremely
difficult to comply with this and I
think it's a real burden on our on our
uh business but it our solution what I'm
proposing is that we do just what the
other states did when they try to
overcome the the quill decision we do
that by overcoming the Mayflower
decision the Wayfair decision the same
way by simply codifying our Constitution
which is what this bill says and it says
that the basically it comes down to
therefore no New Hampshire business
retailers shall be required to collect
sales or use taxes for a foreign
government will provide any information
for the facilitation of collecting these
taxes unless such collect collection is
mandated by the Congress of the United
States in accordance with the commer
Clause Article 1 Section 3 CL laws three
of the United States Constitution where
the Constitution says specifically
Congress has the authority to regulate
interstate commerce not the Supreme
Court or by New Hampshire law and I
think this is would be right for an
overturn on the Supreme Court as Justice
Robert said in his descent uh basically
it should be left up to Congress and
Congress has the opportunity to do this
they have this specific constitutional
authority to do it and they've chosen
not to do it so what this would be is
we're just saying let's do the same
thing that the states did to get quill
overturned we want to do to get wafer
overturned a copy of this has been given
to the attorney general personally uh
back in December I haven't heard any
response from their office so I don't
know what their position is on it but I
think it's incumbent on the state of New
Hampshire to defend our Constitution and
by codifying that portion of the
Constitution it makes it very clear that
if you're in New Hampshire you're not
being governed by other states and it's
just again so we're clear it's not a
simple fact of just collecting the tax
and sending it to somebody else
obviously that costs that's going to be
time and cumbersome but you're going to
have to subscribe to some type of
service to keep track of these 13,000
plus various rates and you're also going
to have to keep track of every product
that you sell to every state so it
doesn't exceed that State's uh
particular uh caps and again that's not
Universal the most common one is 200
Sales or over $100,000 but there are
many states they have no caps at all or
somewhere in between so again it's
another complicated burden on our
companies that want to sell stuff and
clearly both the United States
Constitution which says interstate
commerce is in the hands of Congress and
the New Hampshire Constitution which
says you have to do it by our elected
officials clearly back this bill and I
would hope you'd prove it and I'm
willing to take any
questions thank you representative om
yeah thank you representative heritton
for your description of the Wayfair
decision I'm confused by the bill
however the bill as written talks about
collecting taxes for foreign government
makes no reference to the US states can
you clarify for
us the I was told by um office of
legislative service that foreign
government means any government other
than New Hampshire cor
yeah yes representative Spar um with uh
uh if I understand you the purpose of
this is really to take some of the
owner's burden of of the regulation of
having to get collect these taxes for
these businesses and companies who work
here in the state is that correct well
it's twofold uh obviously to do that as
well but it's also to enforce our
constitution I I find it difficult to
believe that the Supreme Court's going
to rule that the longstanding state of
New Hampshire's Constitution is
unconstitutional okay follow up um the
other states that don't have sales taxes
I think like Delaware Oregon uh Texas
not Texas Alaska and there might be one
other I think but did have they done
anything like this uh not that I'm aware
of no but like I said in the past there
was a movement and we got about 20
states to pass laws to overturn I guess
that was some type of an organized
effort and South Dakota was the first
one that made it through the courts
hence South Dakota versus Wayfair is the
Supreme Court decision um but I mean
nothing wrong with New Hampshire being
first and if other states want to on
it represent
elberger thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I'm I want to
try to make sure I understand the
arguments that you're making
here um I believe what you're saying and
correct me if I get this wrong I believe
that what you're saying is that since
the uh collection of taxes from non New
Hampshire from foreign jurisdictions was
a decision that came from the Supreme
Court and wasn't enacted there's no law
that the United States Congress passed
or the New Hampshire uh legislature
passed that says that those taxes need
to be
collected then despite the fact that the
Supreme Court made a ruling to that
effect we don't have to worry about
it that's basically what it is I'm
saying that I disagree with the Supreme
Court decision uh I think if you if you
look at the the uh Interstate commer
Clause it specifically says Congress has
the authority to uh regulate interstate
commerce uh it doesn't say the Supreme
Court it mentions there's no mention of
the Supreme Court whatsoever they've
sort of invented this secondary Commerce
Clause that they apply to themselves
somehow and again I think uh this was
being pushed by Justice Kennedy big time
he basically told the states bring it to
the Supreme Court and we'll rule in your
favor but it was only five to four I
just think it's right to be overturned
and our constitution is very clear on it
it's very specific if it's not a person
or a person that they get to vote for
then nobody else can impose not only
just taxes but tell them what to do
basically follow up thank you all right
I'm not a constitutional
lawyer I think I remember from 10th
grade civics
that the
has Supreme Court decisions are the law
of the land not of a particular state so
what I'm trying to understand is if the
Supreme Court were to hand down any
other kind of decision that we didn't
like for whatever reason could we say
well we don't like it so you know we
don't want to honor it
no not at all because I mean you have to
look very specifically at the words in
our constitution nor are the inhabitants
of this state controllable by any other
laws than those to which they or the
representative body have given their
consent that's very specific so just a
Supreme Court ruling of something that
we don't care for doesn't mean it's in
violation of our constitution what this
what the states did other states did is
they said we think quill should be
overturned the previous Supreme Court
ision that said you must have a physical
presence in the state in order to force
someone to collect uh the sales tax so
those States pushed the issue into the
court and the court changed that five to
four in Wayfair what I'm suggesting here
is powered by our Constitution which
specifically says this issue is not
allowed in New Hampshire if we're going
to enforce our Constitution that we
should take that and push it back to the
Supreme Court and hope they overturn
Wayfair and say that it it was a mistake
just like they did with ro V
well I thank you for your comment but
I'll also point out that regardless of
whether a decision is 9 nothing or 54 a
decision is still a DEC decision thank
you well I agree with that but I'm just
saying 54 shows that it was not locked
in stone by the Supreme Court that's all
represent thank you represent Harington
yeah I'm right
here not across the a like we were were
last
year the uh question I have is since New
Hampshire ratified the Constitution of
the United
States does not the Constitution of the
United
States have Supremacy over the New
Hampshire
Constitution yes I believe it does but
you can also show me the part in the U
in the United States Constitution where
it says the Supreme Court Shall Set
limits on how you collect sales tax from
other states and if you sell more than
500 units to this state or 200 units
that or it's over 100,000 that this is
clearly legislation by the court and
it's not decare it's not saying a law
was unconstitutional or constitutional
it's saying we're going to we're going
to substitute our judgment for the
Commerce Clause and we're going to
circumvent Congress follow
up yes thank you Mr chair uh
representative
um in order
to contest Court since we have the
supremacy clause in the United States
Constitution what would be the elements
to
trigger
contestation of a decision that is
allowed under the
Constitution that I'm going to have to
defer to so I'm an engineer not lawyer
but I am assuming whatever mechanism for
example South Dakota used to get their
law because they passed a law that said
that disagreed with the Quintel decision
we're I'm suggesting the same approach
we pass a law that disagrees with the
Wayfair decision and that gets pursued
in the courts I would assume the state
would would file to represent uh our
companies in I guess federal district
court and it would move its way up
through that but I I the exact details I
don't know but I know it can be done
because it was done by South Dakota and
other states in the quill decision
follow
up would not
individuals since the state has no
standing would not individuals in the
state have to be
harmed and would this bill give standing
to those
individuals to contest the uh Supreme
Court
ruling well as again as far as the
technical legal issues I'm I'm not a
lawyer but harming they're they're
already harmed anybody who's complying
with the way decision is being harmed
right now because they're spending a lot
of time and effort keeping track of who
they're selling to what and what the tax
rate is I'm sure they be paying someone
to tell them if you sell something to uh
that's a clock to someone in Los Angeles
California you have to charge
11.2% uh sales tax on it but if you sell
clocks to someone in Tennessee don't
worry they're EX EXT so there's already
harm being done and I would think just
like in the case of the of the quill
decision of the overturning the quill
decision it was called South Dakota
versus the versus Wayfair and that's who
that's who took it on and I would see
why I don't see why not New Hampshire
approach representative ORS thank you Mr
chairman and good to see you Mike uh so
this sounds like another New Hampshire
first you know we're we're taking this
because we believe we have our state's
rights
versus the rights of all the other
states we're looking after our state
first it also sounds like an unfunded
mandate to require businesses and
whoever to collect these taxes my
question is has any state ever refused
to follow a scotus
ruling that I don't know I think there
has been some litigation on this and I'm
not sure if states are doing it or
individuals doing it I did get a call
from a couple of businesses and most of
them were small and they said we're
taking the position we don't do enough
business with any particular state to to
kick in their their um the the setting
where we have to start collecting it but
I'm sure there are people in New
Hampshire that sell on larger scales so
when you're talking $100,000 that's not
a lot of money these days and some
states uh the limit is even lower so I
don't I don't know specific speically
how the uh how the individuals uh states
are how the individual companies are
dealing with it but I don't know maybe
there'll be somebody here from the Bia
or something that can speak on that so
follow up follow up so I was thinking in
terms of the Bruin decision when the
Bruin decision came down against New
York state New York State Massachusetts
a lot of the blue State skirted the law
and the Supreme Court decision by
enacting their own laws their own
specific areas of safety or you know saf
zones
whatever uh I know for fact that uh you
know children are taken across borders
for abortion you know we pass laws in
different states limiting the rights of
young people yet you know we say that
they're not smart enough they're not old
enough they're not mature enough to make
decisions on whether it's gambling or
it's smoking or drinking yet we can
change their gender we can let them
change their gender I mean do you think
this is something for the
courts well I think that what we've got
here is in what I'm trying to put is
that our constitution is very explicit
on this I mean it's not just not just
collecting taxes but it says it's
controllable by other law by laws other
than those for which they are the
representative body passed so if
Massachusetts decides to pass a law that
says everyone's got to wear green hats
on Tuesday that can't be enforced in New
New Hampshire and what I'm saying is
this Supreme Court decision which is a
result of laws passed in other states
cannot be enforced in New Hampshire
either thank
you represent
elberger thank you Mr chair thank you
again for taking my question um there
was a comment made by my colleague uh
that this is an unfunded mandate I want
to understand is there any state action
involved
in terms of collecting these taxes no
there's no action by the state of New
Hampshire involved in collecting the
taxes it would be between the individual
company and the state that they you know
the states Massachusetts they would send
the the when they collect their the the
involvement would be okay so they want
to get a pro purchase from Massachusetts
and it's something that's uh has the tax
on it so they would say it's $100 but I
don't know what the sales tax I think
it's 6% so they would collect $100 plus
6% tax that 6% tax then they would remit
to the state of New Hampshire I mean to
the state of Massachusetts new state of
New Hampshire would not be involved
right I I understand that but there is
no Government
funding that's involved in any way in
other states asking our citizens to pay
taxes in their states we're not involved
in trying to collect those taxes the
state of New Hampshire is not involved
so there's no way that in terms of the
government that this is an unfunded
mandate right there's no yeah there is
no unfunded mandate thank
you representative ORS thank you Mr
chairman so this may not be an unfunded
mandate but do you know are there costs
involved in recordkeeping and then
sending taxes across the country to
different states so on so forth I mean
it may not be specifically an unfunded
mandate but it sure sounds like there's
a lot of recordkeeping cost would you
agree or disagree I I think the
confusion here is we're talking about
whether it's unfunded mandate for the
state or individuals clearly this is a
mandate for individuals to spend money
as I said there over 13,000 sales tax
different rates and no one's going to
keep track of that no one's going to be
able to pull off the top of the head oh
you're coming from Dallas Texas you're
know buying a widget so I know exactly
that's a 3.8% sales tax on it uh nope
wait wait a minute there's a special tax
because it's in Dallas they add 1% on so
it's 4.8 obviously you're going to have
to hire some outside firm to keep track
of these thousands and thousands of tax
rates and this it's not only that but
some things that are taxable in one
state aren't taxable in another uh again
using Massachusetts I think the cut off
is if you buy a a jacket for $200 you
pay no sales tax on it if you buy a
jacket for $300 you pay sales tax on the
amount over $200 so there's all these
nuances in the law it would be
impossible to keep track of it plus
you're going to have to keep track of
the total amount because if you get to
that point where you say all right well
I know in South Dakota uh this is going
to be $98,000 and it's September I got
to stop selling stuff to South Dakota
because I can't go back and collect the
taxes that I didn't collect so the only
option I have now is not doing any
business with South Dakota until next
you thank you chair are you aware of any
database that does keep all that uh that
tax information and the ch es in each
state and locality I I'm not aware
specifically but I find it hard to
believe that there isn't one because you
know if you have a state with a sales
tax I'm sure they're they're doing it
already and I how I I can't conceive of
how anyone could comply with it without
having something like that but I don't
know of one specifically just a quick
followup follow up um you know meals and
room tax uh the state here allows uh my
understanding from businesses to keep 3%
of the six or seven whatever it is has
there been any thought as far as maybe
uh as I was thinking out of the box
saying you know for these businesses
this could be a not maybe not a profit
Center but at least a
neutral I'm I'm not aware of any and my
understanding and again I'm not a lawyer
but my understanding of how the Wayfair
decision was is it allows every
individual state to set that so I mean
you could end up a situation where you
know uh Oklahoma says you can keep uh 2%
of this to cover your expenses and New
York says we want it all I I just I I
don't know but it could go that way
because the the Supreme Court basically
allowed the states to set their own for
example the amount of limit on it and
you oh yes we'll take one more question
go ahead representative I I had a
question uh just as an example so if
there was a requirement let let's say
Massachusetts had a sales tax and a
business in New Hampshire was um selling
products with the intention of the
destination being
Massachusetts would uh and they they had
records of that what would prevent the
uh Massachusetts Department of Revenue
from uh conducting an audit of that
organization in New Hampshire well under
the quill decision it was a physical
presence in the state and if I think if
you remember and I don't remember all
the exact details but there was a
situation on that with people buying
tires in Southern New Hampshire under
Governor Lynch and he basically told
them you're not coming up here checking
out people out and you're not collecting
sales tax for sale for tires sold in uh
in New Hampshire that was back I don't
know five or six years ago anyways maybe
more more than that
up I I recall that but in that case the
fact they didn't collect those taxes
were they essentially in abled like if
Massachusetts sent them assessment for
loss Revenue did they have to were they
required to pay that money to
Massachusetts I don't remember the
details but other than I think the way
it turned out is that they did the
governor made it pretty clear that
you're not collecting sales tax from
transactions in New Hampshire and uh go
away and that's why I think it
ended okay thank you very much for your
testimony thank you for listening to me
for such a long time we'll now hear from
department thank you Mr chair um I'm Sam
garland from the Department of Justice
I'm a senior Assistant Attorney General
there and I'm chief of the civil
litigation unit and I know I've seen a
number of you before having testified on
similar uh tax issues and tax questions
um but for those I haven't seen in a
while haven't met it's very nice to be
here and thank you for the
invitation um I I certainly uh am am
simp I guess I should start by saying we
don't take a formal position on on any
bill so we're not I'm not here to oppose
or or support this bill I'm not here to
weigh in on whether it's wise as a
matter of policy I think you've seen our
office um can be quite vigorous in terms
of Defending uh you know the tax
structure that we have in our state at
this point but but I'm not here for any
purpose other than to provide some
technical insight and to answer any
questions that that the committee may
have um I'm certainly sympathetic and
we've seen it at our office to a number
of the issues that representative
Harrington brought to to this
committee's attention Wayfair did upend
um the the pretty cleancut uh physical
presence rule to one that has what's
called an economic Nexus and that there
are tens of thousands of taxing
jurisdictions and it created um serious
compliance burdens for for businesses to
have to comply with other states
fortunately um at least to some extent
states have started to become more
lockstep in how they are setting up
their tax structures so every state in
the country now does have a 1 $100,000
um threshold for an economic Nexus um
there aren't State not every state has
adopted the 200 um transaction threshold
um there are a number of local taxing
jurisdictions um one example we hear all
the time is Alaska where you basically
every municipality within Alaska um can
have its own uh individual uh local tax
rate um but Alaska's also passed
legislation to try to create that to
make that more uniform to have their
municipalities um kind of buy into a
uniform tax structure it hasn't resolved
the question um or or the problem and I
I want to make that clear that we do
still uh in our um implementation
efforts and enforcement efforts for
chapter 78e which was Senate Bill 242 it
was passed in the wake of the W Wayfair
decision interact with New Hampshire
businesses that that Express frustration
with the compliance costs and the
complication of of complying with other
states um uh taxing regimes but I do
think um from where we were in 2018 or
2019 when I was first year to where we
are now um it is a little bit the the
the the things are a little bit more
uniform and and that's certainly an
encouraging development um in terms of
this specific bill um uh the concerns we
have at the Department of Justice are
legal concerns and they're legal
concerns that that kind of um run into a
a practical concern um the legal
concerns are really that and I think
that a number of the members of the
committee and representative Harrington
recognized this we're we're really in um
Uncharted constitutional territory when
we're talking about the interplay both
between the state and federal government
for for Taxation and the states Vis the
other states for taxation that's what we
in constitutional lawyers call vertical
federalism and horizontal federalism um
and so in terms of vertical federalism
um the Supreme Court has never
specifically said that a state can
enforce its tax laws against the
resident of another resident of another
state without an act of Congress but it
certainly strongly implied it that was
an issue that could have come up in
Wayfair it didn't come up in way fair
and the Supreme Court um adopted the
economic Nexus test there without saying
well Congress would need to pass a law
um and there are certainly other cases
older cases from the US Supreme Court
that contemplate for income tax purposes
and other things that one state can tax
the resident of another state in the
absence of an act of Congress and so
there is a I think a serious risk with
this law that it would be challenged on
federal constitutional grounds and as um
representative ol was pointing out could
be subject to a supremacy clause
argument that basically the Federal
Constitution supplants anything that is
in our state constitution in this Arena
and um and so therefore the the the the
effect of our state con constitutional
provision is is doesn't work in the way
that this bill would be designed to have
it work um the other complicating Factor
uh from my perspective is the interplay
with our laws and the laws of other
states because what we would be doing is
we'd be saying our constitution
authorizes the state of New Hampshire to
pass a state statute that exempt state
New Hampshire residents from complying
with other states laws other states I'm
guessing would take the position that
their laws um which uh flow from their
constitution allow them to to tax
residents of other states who are doing
business in their states and that
creates a a constitutional conflict
between one state and another state I
have no idea how that constitutional
conflict would shake out um we've done
some research into it it hasn't really
come up in a way that that gives me any
confidence that if our law was
challenged on those grounds basically
under either the full faith or credit
and Credit Clause of the US Constitution
or What's called the dormant Commerce
Clause the um negative Commerce Clause
of the Federal Constitution whether we
would be able to persuade a court and
ultimately the US Supreme Court that our
law should Trump the law of another
state I mean they would both be
affecting
our law would be affecting businesses in
another state that we're trying to
collect from our residents their law
would be affecting residents of our
state who are doing business in the
state and there's no clear answer to
that question um and so those are
serious constitutional questions and as
someone who does a fair amount of
constitutional law they're extremely
interesting academically I think you
know our job at our office is to defend
the laws that that the general court
passes and the governor signs and I
think there would be good faith
arguments at first blush to defend this
law but but it's certainly not a
foregone conclusion that we would
Prevail in that sort of defense and and
I just want to flag that um it would be
a complicated kind of Uncharted question
the Practical concern that that flows
from that and I raised that this to the
committee in written testimony last year
when a similar bill was before the
committee I wasn't able to come I think
I was out with a sick kid but did put it
into writing is what that where that
leaves New Hampshire taxpayers in the
interim because New Hampshire taxpayers
would have a law that appears to assure
them that they don't have to comply with
other states taxing regimes um but there
would be a serious question whether they
in fact had to do so as a matter of of
federal constitutional law and that
creates um I think a practical risk for
businesses uh whether they're going to
have to be subject to other states laws
notwithstanding our law um and creates a
lot of uncertainty for businesses which
I know folks in the business Community
tell me anytime I interact with them
uncertainty is is not helpful for for
kind of promoting business within the
state um and and at a minimum I think
that creates confusion and uncertainty
um what it also will do and we've seen
this in terms of uh businesses that have
contacted us after Wayfair and um in
conjunction with uh chapter 78e is it's
going to drive up potentially compliance
cost for businesses they're going to we
at the Department of Justice are unable
and it's not unique to this regime to
provide uh either tax advice or legal
advice to to private parties and we
wouldn't be able to take a definitive
position on this anyway and so
businesses would be you know we would
recommend they hire accountants they
hire attorneys and there are obviously
significant costs associated with that
and so th those are really the Practical
concerns that flow out of the UN
uncertain constitutional ground here
that um you know that that I want to
express to the committee um it it's not
to one way or the other on whether this
law is a good idea as a matter of policy
but I do think there are serious
constitutional questions it would
generate and um and potential uh
Downstream effects for businesses um at
least at least until those questions
were resolved I welcome any questions
from the committee thank you represent
elme thank you
um you know that this has been going on
for quite a long time and that the large
majority of states are on the side of
this issue and there is only one on this
side of this issue um but um we did put
in a law which uh I think you're in
charge of complaints to the department
about on what they consider to be
violations of their sovereignty most of
the businesses some the number the
biggest businesses had already before we
did that started
paying uh uh because it was cheaper than
going through a legal system and the
legal system the national one
on but on
how I forget how many years ago it was
you were last year four or I I believe
so it was I believe that was that it was
s242 passed I think in 2019 um it was
passed after I joined the office and
it's now RSA chapter 78e right and uh at
the time you had gotten very few uh
complaints from businesses that they
didn't want to have to obey this and
um you'd resolved them together I
believe but uh have there been a lot
more complaints since there haven't
representative Al me um so so the the
statute you're referring to is RSA
chapter 78e it does a number of
different things one of the things that
it did is it provided an Avenue for
businesses um that were re receiving
Outreach or collection efforts from
foreign taxing jurisdictions to contact
our office um to bring that to our
office's attention to share that
information confidentially not subject
to 91a um so I can't go into the
specifics of Outreach that we've
received what I can say is it's still a
relatively small number um a lot of the
initial Outreach and some of the more
recent Outreach continues to be we don't
know how to comply um and whether we
need to what what do we do and those are
obviously hard conversations because
it's usually we need to advise you to to
talk to your own uh tax Authority or
your own attorney um we have received a
small number and what I can do if it
would be helpful is Supply this
committee with our annual report we
issue an annual report every uh November
um and I believe it probably went to the
the prior chair it was in November 1st
um and so what I can do is I can
certainly send that along after this
hearing today um but that what that
report details is there have been a very
small number of out of Outreach from
businesses um reflecting what appear to
be Bonafide uh collection efforts um and
and we continue to look into them I
probably can't say any more specifically
than that we have not found an instance
so far of either fraudulent efforts to
collect taxes or or efforts to collect
taxes that are clearly uh don't comply
with with federal law or or with state
law
um what I will say too is I think you're
right and at least anecdotally that most
businesses that had the volume of
transactions that would have subjected
themselves to uh forign foreign taxing
effort collection efforts um have come
into compliance that or have made
efforts to do so they've hired
accounting firms or law firms um not
ideal I know for those businesses But
ultimately kind of in the uncertain
ground that we're in um I think has
driven down the number of um number and
then the only other thing I'd add and I
don't really have a great explanation
for this I only really have a few
hypotheses is that it doesn't appear
that we've had that many states making
concerted efforts to collect taxes from
our businesses and it may well be that
there aren't that many New Hampshire
businesses that are doing um enough
business in different states that
they're they're really Hing those
$100,000 thresholds um it may well be
that uh passing chapter 78e kind of let
States know we're taking a close look at
this and and New Hampshire didn't become
a target for that reason um it it may
well be and this may be tooting our own
horn a little bit too much but when we
brought the the original action in the
US Supreme Court against Massachusetts
during the pandemic with respect to
income tax that got a lot of press it
got a lot of press in in both kind of
nationally and in and legal
um journals and it may well be that that
states are aware that if if they run a
foul of what we think the constitutional
laws we're prepared um to to ask a court
to look at it but I I don't know that's
all speculative all I can say is that
the number uh is still relatively low
and we look into the ones that appear to
be bonified collection
ill U thank you Mr G appreciate your um
commentary thus far uh you brought up
the income tax and that uh was my
question um Massachusetts is able to
apply income tax to New Hampshire
residents who are working in because if
I'm understand it correctly IRS rules or
perhaps law say that income tax is
collected where the work is
done and that was the argument that the
New Hampshire made regarding the work
being done in New Hampshire not in
Boston is that correct correct with a
with a little wrinkle but but I don't
have to add it if you don't need it
follow up on that follow up so that
would be the core there was an existing
law currently you're saying that there
is no existing
law should therefore the effort be not
on New Hampshire law but on New
Hampshire Congress
Critters um I I don't want to weigh in
on what I think would be kind of a wise
effort from a policy standpoint what I
will say is that Congress um I think in
in every term for as long as I've been
in this role so so for going on six
years now has considered versions of
bills that um that would have kind of
unified this it's certainly within
congress's Authority um and for one
reason or another they didn't gain
traction but that but that it's not
something that I think is lost on
Congress including New Hampshire's Cong
Congressional Delegation at least you
know four or five years ago when I was
interacting with them more directly
right after the Wayfair decision um and
so if there were folks who were
concerned I I do think that Congress is
the clearest way to to simplify this
that the Supreme Court noted that in
Wayfair and and um and it continues to
be the the clearest way to to create
uniformity across the country would be
through congressional action and I don't
think there's any real legal dispute
that Congress can do that um as a matter
of
Commerce thank you very much for that
statement okay seeing no more questions
thank you very much thank you very much
that is all the pin cards I have for HP
135 is there anyone else who'd like to
speak on
it seeing none I'll close the public
okay the time being 10:47 I'm going to
open the public hearing on HB
Sweeney good morning chairman janigian
and members of the House Ways and Means
Committee uh for the record my name is
representative Joe Sweeney I proudly
represent Rockingham District 25 which
is the town of Salem uh today I am here
to introduce and strongly advocate for
House Bill 155 A measure that reduces
the business Enterprise tax uh bet rate
from
0.55% to 50% % for taxable periods
ending on or after December 31st 2026
effective date would be this July 1st
20125 New Hampshire's strong economy and
our Pro business reputation are the
results of forward-thinking progrowth
policies like this one we know that when
we lower taxes we allow businesses to
keep more of their hard-earned money
which fuels investment job creation and
Innovation House Bill 155 continues that
tradition by delivering meaningful tax
relief to the businesses that drive our
economy and provide jobs for granted
Staters let me be clear this is not just
about cutting taxes it's about creating
Opportunity by reducing the BET rate we
are empowering businesses both large and
small to expand hire and invest in their
communities whether it's a local family
run shop or a larger Enterprise
employing hundreds this reduction
ensures that every business in New
Hampshire has the resources they need to
grow and succeed economic activity is
not a zero sum game when businesses
Thrive the Ripple effects are felt far
and wide employees benefit from better
wages and more job opportunities local
economies are invigorated and our tax
base grows naturally ensuring that the
state has the resources it needs without
burdening taxpayers this is The Virtuous
cycle of growth that we know tax cuts
unleash critics May raise concerns about
the impact on Revenue but the evidence
is clear lower taxes lead to stronger
economic growth New Hampshire has proven
time and time again that reducing tax
burdens Fosters the type of dynamic
vibrant economy that benefits everyone
furthermore the department of revenues
administration's projections while
showing a modest reduction in bet
Revenue do not fully account for the
increased economic activity
corresponding and corresponding revenue
from other sources that we expect
because of this policy and it really
doesn't factor in the BPT offset that
this policy would would still have in
place as stewards of New Hampshire's
future it is our duty to embrace
policies that position our state as the
premier destination for businesses
workers and families House Bill 155 is a
deliberate step in that direction
signaling to job creators that New
Hampshire is committed to their success
and open for business the message we
sent today is simple we believe in the
power of businesses to drive prosperity
and we trust the people of New Hampshire
to spend invest and innovate better than
government ever could I urge you to
support houseo 155 and help ensure that
New Hampshire's economy remains a model
of growth opportunity and fiscal
responsibility and speaking for myself
as a member of the finance committee I
certainly know that any tax reductions
that are made in this committee uh will
be felt and responsible when we deal
with the state budget uh but I know that
we would be able to absorb such a cut
that this one represents uh thank you
for your time and I welcome any
questions the committee may have thank
you representative elme
thank
you
back in
2000 or no it was
before uh it was in the 1990s I believe
the
um
on
the later to
be uh governor for one term Craig Benson
uh started a lawsuit against uh New
Hampshire because we had put in a
business profits tax and it was being
paid almost entirely by the wealthiest
places
on that is how the
BET came to exist was that Governor
Merill decided that it was uh that we
had to solve this lawsuit by putting in
something that would be on all
businesses above a certain
threshold and we've maintained the
inflation effects on that threshold ever
since uh which do help the smaller
businesses to stay uh and
grow why would this not trigger
could this not trigger yet another of
those
lawsuits thank you for the question I I
believe the initial rate of the bet when
it was introduced in the 90s was
0.125% if I'm not mistaken uh it has
grown exponentially from that point to
0.55 uh today this is a very modest
reduction to just
050 uh which is still well above what it
was when it was introduced to an answer
to that lawsuit um I'd be happy to
sponsor legislation with you
representative to bring it back down to
0.125% which was the original uh rate
for but this bill is a simply modest
reduction that I don't think brings us
in any uh trajectory or danger of
triggering
lawsuits if I could it was 025 025 your
your party increased it to 0. five is
there a and then 75 I think it was
uh the
we are now in a time when our revenues
are decreasing rather than
increasing and I'm wondering what you
think we ought to be on getting rid of
in order to do
this uh thank you for the question I
think there's a number of areas in state
government that the house finance
committee is looking at making
reductions at and I also commend the
governor for her Commission on
government efficiency that is also
examining a number of ways in which the
state government can become more
efficient and save taxpayer dollars uh
so I think there's a lot of potential
answers to that question as to where we
can find the the $22 million a year uh
that the analysis says this would uh
free up in taxation uh but we also know
that since 2015 uh We've T cut taxes
significantly in New Hampshire and we've
seen revenues grow year after year after
year uh so I'm confident that any
further tax reductions that we're able
to pursue in the long run will lead to
more economic growth and a and a
stronger tax base over time follow
up uh are you aware that all of the
growth that we've been seeing has been
floating on a sea of uh Republican and
then Democratic Federal stimulus
packages I I think I would just I
disagree with that assessment of what's
fueling the growth and I think it's the
growth in businesses in New Hampshire
that's particularly leading to increased
revenues for the business profits tax
and the the
BET representative or I'm sorry
representative
name representative oery followed by
ORS thank you Mr chair the guy over
here that too yeah um I was just looking
at uh um the uh policy institute's uh or
fiscal policy institutes analysis of the
business Enterprise tax which shows some
23% uh reduction in revenues uh with a
concominant increase in profits and the
two offset each other and my
understanding of the bet is that that's
a tax on hiring
people so you're are you suggesting that
by reducing this by 05%
we're reducing the the cost of hiring
people which would then stimulate
businesses to hire people when there is
a monetary crush on the
business is have I gotten your argument
I I think that sums it up well
representative thank you represent ORS
thank you Mr chairman and good to see
you Joe my hero uh question for you is
uh I saw a presentation put on by the uh
AFP and a gentleman from Josiah Bartlett
uh I wish there was somebody here from
AFP that could uh maybe answer it oh
wait there is somebody here that's right
I do see him now sitting back there uh
but in that
presentation uh what I saw is data from
New Hampshire showing that as we've cut
the tax rate we've grown the revenue
especially to the general front and to
the education trust fund from 25% to 39%
are you aware of that I I am
representative and could you speak to as
to why that's happened maybe I I think
especially thank you for the question I
think we're in a special uh spot of the
country uh where we're a state that's
leading forward on more economic freedom
and lower lowering taxes while
neighboring states are going on the the
opposite direction the opposite path
where they're introducing new taxes
they're taxing millionaires out um and I
think all of that sort of our our our
ability to be that sort of economic
freedom is is in the Northeast has
really driven a lot of our our private
sector growth that is fueling uh
increased tax revenues um so when we can
reduce taxes we can grow revenues at the
same time thank you thank you represent
elberger thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question you talk about
lowering
taxes one of the things that we can pick
and choose is how we Define things it's
true that it it may be true that state
taxes are diminishing but I can assure
you that in
Nashua which is the city I represent or
one one piece of it property taxes have
been going up pretty
consistently what happens is that the
state downshifts costs to people who are
paying property taxes I hear this from
my colleagues around the
state and I
wonder how
the fact that property taxes are growing
growing pretty
consistently meshes with your statement
about taxes
lowering uh thank you for the question I
I would simply state that low taxes are
the result of low spending when it comes
to the local level and we have to have
conversations with our city councils our
town councils our school boards as to
what we're budgeting for what we're
spending locally I serve on the Salem
Town Council I know we examine every
dime uh that we can in Salem to keep
property taxes reasonable for residents
um so it is a conversation on property
taxes that largely is dictated by local
school boards local Town councils
Selectmen uh and the voters who vote for
budgets and warrant articles that may
drive their taxes up um but I at the end
of the day low taxes would be the result
of low spending at the local level all
right so so may I follow up follow up so
I I want to clarify that the fact
that that your interpretation is despite
the state providing less Revenue to the
localities the problem is that
localities who are trying to maintain
services are the problem because we're
raising property taxes so that we can
fund the services that the state needs
to be is that true I I don't know if
that's true because you use the word
need and I think it's always a choice at
the local level as to whether they're
going to increase taxes or they're going
to cut spending so it's that
conversation that has to take place
locally as to what they want their
government to look like what they want
their tax rate to look like and that's
all up to local control and local
elected officials and local voters who
are supporting those policies and that
spending one
more one more followup and then one more
question from thank you Mr chair the
fact that the state is not supporting
public education we are the lowest State
support for per pupil for public
education in the entire country not
something I'm proud of of and the fact
that my city nasua has had to pay $100
million to cover costs for retirement
benefits for First Responders that the
state had committed to and reneged on
apparently is a problem with nasua not
doing its job at managing its economics
is that true I would say all of that
spending you've just referenced were
decided locally to pursue that spending
levels the local governments can always
look to reduce spending if they want to
get tax relief tell that to our First
Responders represent opal yes thank you
Mr chairman and uh thank you for taking
my question representative I I um wanted
to look back at a presentation we had
from the Josiah Bartlett Center um which
I found pretty pretty interesting um I
particularly found uh there were 12
slides that were
presented um
in in presenting these slides uh Mr
Klein was talking about economic freedom
and how nsha was rated highly on
economic freedom and in one chart it it
showed that the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts was clearly not rated so
highly um I think
the organization that was presenting
that had a particular political bent but
I'll leave that aside in the very next
slide I was struck by the fact that uh
New Hampshire was
second uh in terms of growth of GDP
between 200 and
2023 would you care to guess who was
first having not seen the presentation
I'm not going to make an attempt to
guess at the the answer it was the
Commonwealth of
Massachusetts according to the slide
presented by Mr Klein theh abshire's GDP
growth over that 23-year period was 5
54 um while the Commonwealth of
Massachusetts was
61 over 23 years over those 23 years
correct I guess I would answer it as as
we've had a a a decent eight years for
New Hampshire in the last eight years
and we're continuing to grow on those
past eight years that would be my answer
follow up one last one last followup I
don't know of any significant policy
changes in either the Commonwealth or
frankly the state of New Hampshire even
in those 23 years but perhaps you
do
taxes
um no I'm not um we we still have three
more pink cards um and we're getting to
a point where we need to hear from them
um and I would just remind members that
um questions about the bill are fine we
should avoid how we feel about the
policy um thank you representative
n thank you Mr chairman and good morning
members of the committee
um I'm Janine nder I represent the town
of maram Hillsboro 12 in 2022 I
sponsored a bill to cut the BPT and bet
and this committee amended the bill to
just cut a the BPT by a modest
amount um I the sponsor of this bill did
an exceptional job introducing the bill
talk speaking to it and answering
questions so I have nothing to add or
answer um I just wanted to be on record
to support the bill and I thank thank
Moore I love the comfy seed thanks for
the upgrade
uh hello my name is Greg Moore I am a
regional director with Americans for
Prosperity and uh I want to thank the
committee for hearing from me today uh
we are coming here in support of House
Bill
155 uh Americans for Prosperity began
the efforts in 2014 to really highlight
uh New Hampshire's uncompetitively High
business tax rates at the time according
to the tax Foundation we were 48th
nationally we actually had our uh
corporate tax rate is half a point
higher than Massachusetts which is not a
distinction any of us I think would uh
carry as a badge of honor and subsequent
to that there's been five rounds of
relief for the business profits tax and
four rounds of relief to the business
Enterprise tax as representative ner
pointed out she brought in legislation 3
years ago to reduce both the BPT and the
bet this committee chose the BPT uh at
the time I encouraged the committee to
focus on the BET as it impacts uh local
small businesses more more directly than
the BPT um committee made a different
choice and you don't get to win everyone
so uh I would encourage you to really
focus on BET I don't want to be
duplicative of the sponsors uh the
sponsor I will say I will say in regards
to the question he received relative to
uh local
spending uh New Hampshire is sending a
record amount of money to local
governments record amounts both in
direct cash payments as well as in
education funding what has changed in
the last few years and I say this uh
because uh with America's Prosperity I
actually oversee the work of 16 States
and we're seeing this across the country
is that the the impact of The
Disappearance of federal money has made
a major impact on a lot of local
governments and a lot of local
governments uh did what they did what
happens when a A Rush of new money comes
in they spend up to the new money and
when that money disappears it has to be
made up by local tax dollars so I will
say that it's uh it's a byproduct of a
lot of Disappearing money that's that is
a fair statement but it's not State
money uh the state has been sending a
record amount of money to local
governments and has been for the last
few years so with that I'd be happy to
questions represent
elberger thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my
question we've had testimony or
presentations by a variety of groups
about finances one of which was the Bia
the business and industries
Association if the reduction of
taxes was CR a critical priority for
them can you help me to understand why
they are telling us that their
priorities are increased housing and
child care opportunities they are not
asking us for a reduction in taxes and
I'd just like to hear what your thoughts
are on that thank you for the question I
I appreciate it uh there'll be a speaker
after me uh who speaks for the national
Federation of Independent Business so I
think you'll get a very different
perspective from small business and from
the larger businesses represented by the
Bia um small business obviously is
uniquely impacted by the BET versus the
BP
uh and I will say that that there's no
question that there are other challenges
facing the state of New Hampshire
housing is an enormous priority and then
we're and we at AFP are putting a large
focus on that in fact after I leave this
committee I'm going to go to a lunch and
we're we're we're hosting with the uh
head of the National Association of home
builders to highlight that very issue so
uh two things can be true it I don't
think I don't live in a world where uh
just because one thing is a priority for
one group then therefore other things
are not a priority or that they will be
opposed I haven't seen any opposition
from the Bia to this legislation thank
you representative Southworth uh thank
you um just for my math a little bit I
think you are correct that New Hampshire
is currently um contributing the most to
uh public education than it ever has
I've been here 10 years so I think that
is correct um would you also agree
though that our percent contribution is
the lowest in the United States and is
way off from some of the other
neighboring uh New England
states I will say that it that it is
lower than the other New England states
I could not say definitively if it's the
lowest I know that that uh a number of
the other New England states use other
direct taxes like sales taxes to
directly fund uh education so since we
don't have a sales or an income tax it
would be hard for us to utilize those
exist thank you for the question
okay seeing no more questions thank you
Reynolds thank you uh Mr chair and
members of the committee I appreciate
the opportunity to testify in support of
of House Bill 155 today my name is John
Reynolds I'm the state director for the
national Federation of Independent
Business in New Hampshire we represent
1700 over 1700 small businesses across
the state in every industry every
sector uh our members are typically very
small um and our mission is to promote
and protect their right to own operate
and grow their business um I want to say
when I traveled around the state last
fall and this winter talking to our
members uh the number one thing I heard
from them is business taxes right they
have a lot of different problems and
challenges right now from uh trying to
find Qualified workers trying to pay
them more um you know making repairs
buying equipment you name it but the
number one thing the first thing out of
their mouth almost universally was was
the tax burden uh and then that shows up
you know in our surveys as well and one
thing I I want to hearken back to right
is uh Over The Last 5 Years small
businesses in this state across the
country have faced almost almost
unprecedented challenges at least in the
last 40 50 years and while the start of
the pandemic kind of seems like it's
getting to be you know well in the
rearview mirror uh the reality for a lot
of our members uh we survey them
regularly we ask them questions about
their economic health and the state of
the small business economy during the
pandemic we regularly surveyed them on
some unique questions and one of them
was uh how is covid affecting your sales
and it you know reported back like you
would expect in the first year or two
which are that you know half to 3/4s of
small businesses rep reported
significant declines in their sales but
I think what people don't necessarily
realize is that lingered on for a long
time we cut the last edition of that
survey was in January of 2023 and at
that point still a third of small
businesses were reporting that their
sales were down 25% or more compared to
pre pre- pandemic levels so digging out
of that whole um has looked a lot
different for a lot of our members a lot
of small businesses than than other
people uh which is why we support a
reduction in the BET which to
representative ul's Point uh would allow
them to hopefully keep up put a little
bit more money back in the business
pocket to keep up with hiring to pay
their employees a little bit more to
hopefully retain them and attract new
ones to make repairs to buy new
equipment and invest back in their
business and and hopefully grow here or
allow more businesses start here and
continue to grow New Hampshire's economy
so uh we're happy to support uh House
Bill 155 thank representative Sweeney
for sponsoring it and I appreciate again
the opportunity to comment
today thank you representative elmy
thank you
um I have two questions if I could uh
one of them is Washington defines small
businesses as anything under 500 workers
that is a large business for New
Hampshire and I'm wondering on what your
membership can actually consists of
within the New Hampshire version of what
small businesses are sure uh I mean uh
thank you represent V me and Mr chair uh
80% of our members have fewer than 20
employees so when I say small I mean
very small you know talking hardware
stores small machine shops uh auto
repair stores uh small grocery stores
maybe a few General Stores um the US
small business administration does
Define small business across the board
generally as under 500 and then they
have industry specific categories that
range from 100 to 1500 employees
depending on what industry it is because
when you get into some specialized
manufacturing right you know you you you
could have a thousand employees and be
apple have a follow yeah thank you for
that I've been wondering for a long time
uh the the other question
is about whether you've had a
conversation with those people about
which taxes are their
problem
because uh there's quite a lot of
um people a lot of them are paying more
business than um uh property taxes than
they are any other
tax and do they regard are they talking
mostly about property tax or which are
growing because we are cutting we are
sending Services back down to the towns
uh to pay for or are they talking about
our business Enterprise taxs yeah I and
I represent Aly thank you for that
question um and that's something I would
like to dig into deeper with our members
and ask them specifically which burden
is the worst the most common answer I
get anecdotally is all of them uh
you know and any and any reduction any
relief whether it comes from property
taxes or or the Statewide uh bet BBT and
others um you know is very welcome and
then one other thing I did want to note
too you know at the end of this year a
really important Federal deduction the
federal small business deduction which
allows small business owners to deduct
20% of qualified business uh expenses
expires at the federal level and if that
goes away I mean that's going to have a
really detrimental impact on small
businesses in new Hamp sure um I hope it
doesn't you know we're working we have a
team in Washington that works very hard
on that I'm glad not to be here I'm very
glad to be here um but you know
certainly a reduction in the bet would
help offset the loss of that Federal
deduction representative ORS thank you
Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question so you may have touched on it
but you said that the small businesses
were really hurting due to the covid
where are they at presently have they
recovered or how far behind are they
yeah we um thank you uh reprentative for
the question uh we we stopped that P
specific pandemic era survey uh in Janu
two years ago this month um so I don't
have you know continuation of that where
their sales are but I just thought it
was striking that even three years into
the pandemic that sales were still
significantly below pre-pandemic levels
for one and three small businesses um
you know what I would say right is uh
what I see in our current data we have a
great we have 300,000 members around the
country so we survey uh them regularly
every month kind of on this the health
of their businesses um and what they you
know continue to report are problems are
are wouldn't be a surprise right it's
inflation is one of the still one of the
top problems depending on what uh what
you do what line of business you're in
supply chain issues still might be a
problem for you and then uh the cost of
Labor and also availability of workers
right are just chronic problems that the
pandemic exacerbated thank you that are
still problems representative Southworth
uh thank you chairman thank you for
taking my question um have you seen I
think it's from the Dr the chart that
shows where the tax reductions actually
go when we lower the taxes because it's
kind of an upside down triangle and the
top the big money is going to large okay
good so depending where you draw your
line about what's a small business you
can see on that chart that whatever
we've done in the past 10 years most of
the reductions have gone to
multinational corporations large
businesses New Hampshire and so on and
we we get that report from them uh every
two years when we do the budget so I
just wanted certainly I'm a strong
supporter of the small businesses but if
I look back I've been here 10 years most
them that's sort of a mix of a question
oh yeah sorry I was waiting I'm glad you
have that in front of you yeah no I I I
think it's a great chart thank you
representative Southworth for the for
the comment um I have not seen a
distribution of kind of you know buy uh
tax spur in or yeah I have not seen a
distribution of how this they have a
nice but I can you know you can pretty
easily do a back of the math calculation
and figure out that you know I just
think that would be helpful information
yeah but say for 10 15 uh you know
employee businesses right you know
whether this saves them a few hundred
bucks or a few thousand bucks right
that's meaningful um so you know I'm not
going to
knock it's it's meaningful to to our
thank you one last question from
represent elberger you miss thank you Mr
chair this is more of a Quest type of
question following up on representative
ORS I was struck by the fact that you
had stopped that survey in 2023 which
was sort of the end of the worst of the
pandemic and now I would ask if you can
do it again because I'm wondering
whether the responses might be
significantly different thank you happy
to we we are a uh uh I I like to think
of it as a lean But Mighty organization
but still lean so we kind of have to
shift our resources around when sort of
our our data research team is pretty
small but I will look and see what we
have and see if we can kind
of figure out sort of a line of where
sales are and where overall Business
Health is but as I mentioned to
represent or is you know it's it's the
concerns you all know
about thank you very
much okay last I have a card from uh
pinard from Dr if people have questions
okay seeing
none uh we will not call Dr up um and I
okay next I will open the public hearing
on HB
and do we have a pink card
representative
opal we'll start us
off thank you Mr chairman and members of
this committee um we had a little bit of
a uh audible this morning so um I'm
going to speak off notes rather than are
prepared uh I'm speaking uh as the
co-sponsor uh with represent shamberg uh
of House Bill
502 um the idea behind this bill is very
simple Hampshire faces a fiscal crisis
we all know that we've all heard
it um and a big part of that fiscal
crisis is the impact on our property
taxpayers um I had the opportunity as
I'm sure all of you did of going around
and talking to my constituents or my
those that I hoped would be my
constituents back last
fall and the number one issue that I
heard from them businesses and
individuals alike was property
taxes now it's easy to say well it's a
spending issue you know they just need
to vote differently but the fact of the
matter is uh we have a long tradition of
democratic decision making in this state
that is actually fairly
unique um and I take some issue with
people who suggest that voters in a
community who make a a
decision um are are somehow
wrong
um those voters are doing their best to
provide
resources that this state is not has not
been
providing and that's not just my opinion
that's the opinion of several Court
years that's issue one issue two is the
fact that New Hampshire businesses are
not competing on a Level Playing Field
with multinational corporations
particularly foreign
corporations who continue to have the
ability to profit
shift and there are those who will say
well the tax cut and jobs Act of 2017
solved this problem it
didn't study after study has shown that
corporations multinational corporations
continue to use property or profit
shifting uh to lower or in some cases
evade
taxation um that's not a Level Playing
Field if I have a the Hampshire business
I'm paying my full liability tax
liability um it's a fairly simple
process to say shouldn't
everybody based on their activity here
in the
Hamshire what this bill would do is
called complete corporate
reporting and it is true that no state
at this moment uses complete corporate
reporting alone but 11 states do offer
it as an option and the state of
Alaska requires oil companies to use
complete corporate
reporting to apportion their taxes owed
to the state of Alaska so this is not a
unique Concept in fact in the
1980s a number of States including the
state of New Hampshire had what was then
called worldwide combined
reporting it is the same idea as
complete reporting and we in fact
require compan ianes who do business in
New Hampshire to provide us their
combined reporting for their activity
domestically the only thing we say is
we're not going to take a look beyond
the water's
edge and that enables companies to
continue to do what some call
euphemistically transfer pricing what we
all know as profit
shifting uh to low tax or no tax
jurisdictions like Ireland or the became
in
Islands
um there was a study done by The
Institute for Taxation and economic
policy in
2019 that said this was a17 billion
problem for the
country and 177
million uh loss of income for the State
Hampshire I don't know of any study more
recent than that
but I do know that study exists and
there are a lot
of
anecdotal and theoretical discussions
about what this would do whether it
would produce more revenue or not I'm
sure there would be winners and losers
as Dr said uh but the fact of the matter
is there is at least one documented
study that suggests this would produce
significant income for the State of New
Hampshire without impos imposing a new
tax simply by requiring everyone to play
by the same
rules
um and with that Mr chair I'll be happy
to try and answer any questions I'm not
an accountant I'm not a lawyer but I do
know what's fair thank you
representative Spar Spire thank you Mr
chair you say that they're shifting uh
these corporations large multinationals
are shifting profits uh to foreign
countries because of tax
purposes um what is uh the federal
government doing about that because
they're I would think they're trying to
you know that these corporations are
doing that because they don't want to
pay federal taxes not necessarily the
state of New Hampshire correct that is
correct there have been um uh at the
federal level there have been several
efforts um uh the the tax cut and jobs
act considered you know included
Provisions that were trying to claw back
um primarily jobs and and companies that
had moved
overseas uh there's also something
called guilty which I forget exactly
what the
acronym um stands for but an effort to
to uh to tax some of this profit
shifting but there are several studies
that have shown that it it has not done
um it has not done what it hoped to do
in terms of you know uh ending the
profit shifting and and and allowing or
making sure the companies were paying
their fair share I know there are
several States um state of Oregon state
of Minnesota almost passed this uh the
state of Maine and the state of Vermont
and the state of Rhode Island all looked
at it
um and I would say that for example the
state of Minnesota it it passed one
chamber of their legislature and was
about to pass another and um there was
significant lobbying activity um
and somehow it
failed so there have been efforts at
both the Fate State yeah both the
federal and and many state levels uh to
change
this representative
Lori thank you for taking my question
you also testified at the commission
hearing that was chaired by uh um Mr
attorney spillsbury formerly of this
committee
um appreciate that and I'll ask a
similar question that I asked at that
time why does New Hampshire
care about a company that's in New
Hampshire and hires
people about a ship building operation
that is within the same
Corporation 6,000 miles
away that we would have that our Dr
would have to receive a report on and
evaluate to to determine it seems to me
that this particular Bill while being
fair would place an unfair burden on
large corporations to do increasing
amount of work in making New
Hampshire
less popular place for large
multinationals to come and spend their
money well representative oy thank you
for your question um uh a couple things
uh first first of all I would suggest
that the argument that this is going to
place an unfair burden in terms of
reporting requirements on large
companies um if companies aren't already
collecting this data then my suspicion
is um it's either really egregiously
poor oversight on the part of the
company and its leadership um and that
company is probably not long for for
business if they're not already
understanding
what their Global you know what the what
the scope of their operations are it's
also true that um in many other
jurisdictions including the European
Union for example these kinds of reports
are required so companies are already
gathering this this data now to the
first part of your question why is it
why would we care um I think we would
care
because whether it's tax policy or any
other issue that deals with
fundamentally the rule of
law ultimately what holds that up is an
understanding on the part of all
citizens that it will be applied equally
and fairly and if I have a New Hampshire
business and I'm being taxed at a
certain rate on all of my
sales um then it seems to me Eros ER in
potentially of my confidence in that
system if I'm allowing a multinational
corporation to use what are now
perfectly legal I will admit but I think
unfair accounting
techniques to transfer profits from
sales in New Hampshire to uh a lower tax
jurisdiction let me give you one
example um the pharmaceutical industry
is sort of famous for this where a a
drug will be developed let's say and I'm
going to use OIC not because I want to
attack that drug or that company but I
just it's a drug we're all familiar with
advertising if if pharmaceutical company
X develops OIC and achieves $100 million
US that company's headquarters in the
Cayman Islands then charg es the US
affiliate a licensing fee to sell
ozempic and that licensing fee even
though the company has no employees or
or few employees in the Cayman Islands
and they had nothing to do with
developing or marketing the drug that
licensing fee then sucks a substantial
portion of the
profit and suddenly that all those 100
million dollars in sales become
significantly less when it comes time
for our deal
or any other state taxing Authority or
the federal government uh to consider
their
liability representative ORS thank you
Mr chairman thank you rep for uh taking
my question so I you know I've read
through this uh I I have to admit I
can't seem to get my head around it and
being a controller a vice president of
Finance someone who's done taxes across
state lines I find this uh extremely
difficult to follow uh but my first
question is I I couldn't understand
you're talking about leveling the
playing field and a complete corporate
reporting and so on what is complete
corporate reporting I mean it sounds
like you're asking to change the tax
code I mean do you know how many
millions of pages the tax code is
already I mean I'm not sure where you're
going with this other than that you're
trying to increase taxes on
businesses which could drive them out of
New Hampshire so mik what is what is the
goal here there's so much going on here
I mean can you and give me in like five
bullet points what you're trying to
do I I will certainly try representative
thank you for the question um the goal
is very simple um if you're a company
doing business in New Hampshire and
you're also doing business around the
world
all this asks is that you provide the
data that says okay we had you know 100
million in sales
globally and our sales in New
Hampshire
were I can't do the math in my head but
let's say it's a million dollars right
so that's 1% of my Global
sales okay so that would be based on
your your tax liability would be based
based on that calculation 1% of your
Global sales as opposed
to being enabled through accounting
techniques to take that million dollars
in profit and shift it elsewhere and we
don't look beyond the water's edge
currently and
so uh you know it's a it's a different
calculation if we can't compare what you
what your the totality the complete
report of of your operations this this
bill this change would have no effect on
uh any businesses that are not
multinational
corporations um
and well I'm sure I enjoy uh purchasing
from multinational corporations like
Amazon um I'm I'm not going to feel
sorry for them having to add another
accountant a lawyer or two um and the
and as I say I think most of this
information
if not all of it they're already
collecting they're just not sharing it
with
Dr um follow follow so last year uh I
believe representative shamberg had a
bill dealing with waterers Edge and
taxing and again it was so complicated I
couldn't I couldn't get my head around
it and I've already mentioned my
background uh I spoke with a gentleman a
representative used to be on ways and
means I wish he was here uh spillsbury I
think is last name is and uh yeah I saw
you back there but uh you know he tried
to explain it to me and I think he's a
pretty sharp guy for a Republican and uh
you know I could I still couldn't
understand it I mean this this sounds to
me like I mean we're already generating
these businesses are already gen
generating tax reports why can you not
get the information from their tax
reporting which is quite substantial
having been in this Arena
because under current
law we're essentially prohibited from
looking beyond the water's edge so any
activity by a multinational corporation
that takes place and Waters Edge I guess
is sort of a euphemism because I you
know it includes any International
including Canada or Mexico um we can't
that can't be considered
um so so we don't have the information
and we can't get the information that's
you know that's as simple and again I
will say that I think the issue here and
I highly respect repres representative
spillsbury and we had several
conversations about this um we don't we
don't agree we I think we've agreed to
disagree um but the fact of the matter
is uh it is not that complicated when
you look at it at it at its heart all
we're asking for is companies to provide
100% of the information of their
activities
so that they can pay their full tax
liability to the state of New Hampshire
just like every New Hampshire business
has to do so we're just that's the level
of playing field your business if you're
doing business in New Hampshire you pay
your taxes uh if you're a multinational
you have means of of lowering that tax
bill and again it is currently legal but
I don't think that makes it right I I
think it is it is legal excuse me follow
I just want to make one comment is I
think the solution is we need to change
the tax code if that's what you want to
do but I'm glad we cannot see past the
water's edge thank
you okay I'm going to take one more
question and then I know representative
spilsbury is here and he's also in a
committee uh meeting so yes
representative shamber uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking this
question uh representable
looking at the bill
itself it became more complicated when I
was asked to add some additional issues
into the bill by outside
sources and I excuse me uh you'll have
to suspend you are on the bill you
should not be asking questions I can't
ask any question now oh sorry about that
I was going to ask about an amendment
but I'll leave that till later okay if
if if May Mr chairman Just One Last
Point um what I failed to mention and
and is uh it it it is the intention of
Representative shamberg and myself if
given the opportunity um we got this
this last draft fairly late and there
was additional information um or
additional issues that were added
regarding uh the Statewide property tax
and um and issues related to the
Statewide property tax that uh
representative Ames I believe introduced
last year he has now we found out I
found out yesterday that he has now
reintroduced that Bill separately and so
there are provisions of this bill that
we would seek to amend and strike um and
his bill is being heard by uh another
committee later this week is my
understanding so it's probably more
appropriate for those issues to be dealt
with separately and removed from 502 so
that we can focus on the issue of uh
complete reporting thank
you thank you very
much all right uh next I've got
representative spillsbury I saw him
filling out a pink card and the only
other pin card I have is Dr which we'll
invite them if there's further questions
thank
you good morning w and Means Committee
I've been missing you this topic uh
certainly brings me back to the last two
terms um I
would strongly ask you to itl this bill
I did notice it was more complex and I'm
going to confine what I'm going to
address simply to the worldwide combined
reporting uh we don't do commissions on
very many of our topics ICS two terms
ago we were asked to pass a bill to
create a
commission and a commission meaning both
members of the Senate and the house as
well as a variety of outside
interests and give this a thorough study
and uh I was appointed to that and by
happen stance found myself as chairman
which I didn't anticipate but it
certainly forced me to take a deep dive
and I just want to uh ask uh the
chairman please to circulate the
commission's report and I want to ask
each of you to please take the time to
read the majority uh report is 16 pages
long it will give you the most
comprehensive uh review of the topic I
think that you can find anywhere and if
you really want to go further uh the
report includes uh a very extensive uh
several page bibliography
I don't imagine that there are many of
you who want that but it's there I've
had many
compliments uh from people involved in
tax conferences and other states for the
comprehensive Clarity of that report and
I would suggest to you that I went out
of my way as chairman of that to make
sure that it touched every single issue
that surfaced regardless of whether it
was in favor or in
opposition they're spelled out what each
of the people who testified including Mr
Opel is laid out and it's a it's not a
transcript but it'll give you a very
very clear idea of what was said uh
during the various uh hearings and
held we basically when we tax business
in income are asked to tax what happens
in New
Hampshire but we know the world is
complicated and so we have allocation
formulas apportionment
formulas those add an enormous level of
complexity to business tax law when you
take those apportionment formulas and
you apply to the business activity
across 50
states that adds enormously to the
complexity
and in fact the complexity in in is such
that we have different laws in the
different states entirely different
approaches to taxing
businesses and we've recently uh tried
to simplify that apportionment formula
process in New Hampshire by going to the
single sales Factor this was to simplify
a ridiculously complex
process what worldwide combined
reporting would do is it would blow the
complexity up to an entirely different
level and for that
reason no State applies worldwide
combined reporting with the single
exception that in
Alaska they apply it exclusively to the
oil and gas
industry it's not that the other states
haven't considered it in fact just in
the last half dozen years proposal
similar to this have failed in Minnesota
Maine Rhode Island Indiana and those um
those legislative activities are also um
addressed and links to them in our
report but most importantly the federal
government does not use worldwide
combined reporting the federal
government since the business tax was
created applies an arms length
adjustment process
it's very textured it's multivariant
it's subjective and it gives the IRS the
tools to make adjustments for things
such as royalties and licenses and
intellectual property and that's how the
United States government satisfies
itself that it's getting its fair share
of corporate income tax now the beauty
of the New Hampshire uh business tax is
that we use the federal tax return as a
Point of
Departure and you take your adjusted um
uh or your net taxable income and you
make certain limited
adjustments I don't want to go into all
the rationals in the description I want
to urge you to read the report the level
of complexity that comes when you say we
need to know what happened in New
Hampshire and how to tax it and we're
going to find that out by learning and
inquiring about the entire worldwide
operations of multinational corporations
is insane and for our state to do it
when no other state does it and when the
federal government isn't doing it means
we're going to get no assistance from
anybody the Dr testified to the
commission when we asked them what would
this involve the answer was more more
more of everything more staff more
training more tools more travel budget
Etc I
think that this is based on a conceptual
theoretical
problem I think that the tools already
available through arms length adjustment
are
ample I think that um steps being taken
recently in the uh oecd and the
international environment are also
addressing this I think the fact that we
tax guilty
income and foreign earned
dividends dramatically mitigates the
problem the problem isn't sufficient to
Warrant the level of Warrant the level
of complexity that the bill would
require so the commission report doesn't
deny the existence of the problem or its
potential
but it very much puts it into scale this
is not worth doing for New Hampshire if
I thought that there was a sufficient
amount of cheating and that we really
had another source of income I would
have supported it but after all that the
commission went through I concluded that
on balance it could not be supported and
I think it's very unfortunate after that
level of study and after the vote that
was taken last term that it's come back
please
itl uh what was the vote on that
commission the vote of the commission
was 7 to one I
believe to not to not do this 7 to one
opposed to the idea of worldwide
combined reporting thank
you represent
elberger thank you Mr chair nice to see
you again representative thank you
represent Elber
I believe and please correct me if I'm
wrong that at some point during our
conversations last
year uh we got information
about the effective tax rate for a local
business doing a similar business to an
international company and what the
difference in terms of tax rate was do
you recall that or is this something I'm
making up I'm I'm not recalling the
discussion but when we say tax rates 7
and a
half% but in follow up what I'm trying
to remember
is did we ascertain or come up with the
the notion that a local business was in
effect paying more than an international
corporation no I don't I don't know how
you could make that calculation or how
you would impute that outcome I mean
that from a the standpoint of available
facts in
mathematics
um what we know is that the net taxable
income is subjected to the same rate
regardless of what sort of a business or
business okay followup
follow it sounds to me as though you're
saying that the major objection to doing
something like this is that it would be
difficult is is that a correct
interpretation I I think that's a fair
interpretation and and I don't mean to
say that it's the only reason for not
doing it but I do agree that it's the
major reason for not doing it so if you
please read the report 16 Pages doesn't
take that long and I know it's a little
dreary but you are the tax committee um
the the complexity in uh accounting
rules which veryy country to Country in
currencies in languages in regulatory
regimes in tax codes is so great I
worked for a corporation that was in 78
countries I just can't even imagine how
that company could have squarely
complied with this so when you have
something that involves as much
uncertainty in so far as the potential
benefit then I think you really do need
to weigh the certainty of how complex
and involved it would be not only in
terms of the resources that would be
required of the
tax uh reporting entity but also of our
you thank you very much it's good to
visit good to have you
here all right uh last um Lee but not
least I will invite Dr up well actually
let ask does do people have questions of
please good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee I'm Jennifer Ramsey I'm
tax policy Council for
Dr thank you and I'm looking forward to
soup because it's cold outside yes it
is you just heard representative
spillsbury talk about the cost to
operate
this and I seem to recall that some
testimony was given both in the
commission and in the committee
regarding that cost what would be the
administrative cost to
review the
entire combined reporting
of even a small multinational
corporation
um thank you for the question
representative ol I did sign up to speak
today because I had a couple of
um texal uh issues I wanted to bring to
your attention regarding the bill but
also I wanted to be sure that you uh
understood um Dr is not taking a
position with respect to this um with
this bill but uh we did want to be sure
to that you understood that there would
be a cost associated with administering
and implementing it um so we have taken
a look at what it would take to
implement the bill uh we would need to
develop new forms um there is a
challenge with respect to section four
of the bill because uh as representative
spillsbury said um we currently start
from a line on the federal tax return um
but that line does not include um all of
the entities that this bill would expand
to include so that would probably no
longer be the right place to start so
there's a a logistical problem with with
that that that I would ask you all to
give some thought to um other than that
I think our cost would be in expanding
our audit division to try to figure out
how to audit um these taxpayers and we
estimated for purposes of the fiscal
note that that would would uh at a kind
of an intermediate level of auditing
would add three Auditors to our staff we
would need to contract initially at
least for services from professionals
that had foreign language expertise and
foreign U tax expertise um and there
would be additional travel costs uh
the the amount that we um estimated for
those costs would be in fiscal 26 an
additional uh m 164,000 in fiscal 27 an
additional M26 63,000 and in fiscal year
you yes
Robi yes I have a question it was said
that um this already exists in the
European Union but um legally could we
uh require this
only of the United States and the
European Union or and whatever other
group already had a
robust uh audit system of their own um
thank you for the question
representative Aly I do think you could
um do this or something like this um it
would simply be a question of the
it right
represent
elberger M thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my
question how much do you are you
estimating would be the the cost I'm not
talking about the Personnel but the cost
of trying to implement this um so the
additional personnel and the uh cost for
contracted Services as well as travel
costs were the numbers that I just
provided earlier in add addition to that
um modifying the tax forms and creating
uh the portal I think was something we
believed we could absorb um within our
ordinary
expenses of the
agency
and follow and I'm sorry
followup is this the chart you're
referring to here says uh for fiscal
1.64 uh a million 164 yes it's it's in
the fiscal note um I'm not sure if
that's made it to you yet I know uh it
was not originally attached to the bill
and I don't know if you have the updated
fiscal fiscal note that was sent to the
house clerk but it's now in the fiscal
note as well as in the fiscal note quick
guide that we provided uh yesterday all
right uh followup follow up so we're
looking at a cost of
let's a million and a half
chances are that if we were to do
something like this to spend the money
and the training and all of that we'd
get a whole lot more than a million and
a half so I mean it it it just I
recognize the expense but I'm wondering
whether it might not be worth the
expense for the gain the we have not uh
attempted to estimate the gain I think
the belief is that there would be some
winners and some losers as
representative spillsbury said um but
certainly if you all believe that this
would be a huge Revenue generator then
um I I follow your thought thought
process um it's it's just not something
that we would have a a way to estimate
thank
you okay uh represent El me
yeah what we'd be looking at wouldn't it
be was would be we've got this bucket
of that that is the entire Corporation
we knew about this part of it down here
on the amount of Revenue that came in
from this part down here would be
divided by
um would be a result of of how much
revenue they they got in New Hampshire
itself divided by the rest of that that
bucket piece of the bucket are you
speaking about the apportionment rules
yes I think what you're saying is
correct with respect to apportionment um
that we do look right now at a unitary
group of of related corporations files a
single uh Waters Edge combined tax
return starts from the income for the
whole group and then a portions the
amount to New
Hampshire now based on Strictly on the
sales in New Hampshire versus the sales
everywhere um that's what representative
spillsbury
meant if I could sure on everywhere
inside the United States correct so if
we used the whole bucket we would also
be having to use the
entire
Revenue um gained from the whole bucket
So when you say the whole bucket are you
talking about companies outside of the
waterers Edge group Outside The Waters
Edge group yes so um so we would be
again dividing what was New
Hampshire's to the entire
world and wouldn't there be some risk
there that New Hampshire relative to the
entire world was a smaller amount of
money than New
Hampshire relative to the US I think
what you're getting at if I understand
it is the idea that there would be some
any more questions for
Dr okay seeing none thank you very much
um Mr chairman may I may I point out
just really quickly two other small
section
five of the the bill there's an
authorization uh to Dr to engage in
worldwide combined reporting tax
practices um my audit team is telling me
they think that that would more
appropriately belong in RSA 77 A2 or
A6 um and then also in section six of
the bill there's a definition of foreign
dividends um that is modified but I
don't believe you would need a
definition of foreign dividends anymore
because that would be included in
foreign
okay is there anyone else who would like
to testify on HB
502 seeing none we'll close the public
502 okay that concludes
the schedule for this morning so we will
ready to itl that one I mean the
commission a commission Terry is very
good and that that commission voted 7 to
one and it was bip
time
e
being 105 we'll get started here I'll
open the public hearing on HB
4177 and um invite representative
bill good afternoon Mr chairman m the
committee thank you for uh me me to
introduce the house bill 417 uh which
seeks to lower the communication
Services tax in its first year and
repeal it entirely in the second this
proposal reflects a commitment to Fair
taxation administrative Simplicity and
reducing unnecessary burdens on New
Hampshire's residents and businesses uh
this testimony represents My Views and
most importantly the views and interests
of my constituents in the towns of
Alexandria Bridgewater Bristol Kanan
dorer and field Grafton Grotton Hebron
and orange and my testimony is not made
on behalf of any private employer uh nor
should it be construed to represent the
views of any of my employers uh the
communication Services tax today first
of all lacks a clear purpose uh or
incentive it's a relic of a bygone era
enacted when telecommunications were a
luxury rather than an essential utility
uh communication services today are
Necessities for everyday life whether
for work education or social engagement
unlike other taxes designed to
incentivize or discourage certain
behaviors the CST serves no broader
policy purpose and it arbitrarily
singles out communication services to
generate Revenue without aligning with a
public policy goal second the tax is
regressive the CST disproportionately
impacts low-income residents
communication services are essential and
low-income households spend a larger
percentage of their income on these
services compared to wealthier
households by increasing the cost of
living for those least able to afford it
this tax exacerbates Financial
inequality in our state third it is an
administrative complexity and a burden
on businesses it is complex for the
communication service providers
themselves to administer these vendors
are so frustrated with the complexity of
determining what is taxable and what is
exempt particularly when it comes to the
exclusion that we introduced a few years
ago around internet services which are
supposed to be you know excluded of
course both with our law and with
federal law that they simply Tax
Services which shouldn't be covered and
when challenged admit their error and
continue to pay the tax anyway because
they cannot get their their systems
right on the billing side for smaller
businesses and startups the burden of
compliance creates just one more barrier
to entry stifles competition and
innovation in New Hampshire's economy
New Hampshire takes pride in its low tax
environment particularly uh when it
comes to these kind of taxes that are
not apportion to a particular use or to
align to a particular public policy
purpose repealing the CST reinforces our
commitment to being an attractive state
for residents and businesses and in an
era where remote work and digital
connectivity are increasingly important
reducing the cost of communication
Services makes new New Hampshire even
more appealing to businesses and to
individuals seeking to relocate the bill
uh before you takes a phased approach
which is a deliberate choice to balance
fiscal responsibility with the need for
reform reducing the tax in the first
year allows time to evaluate and adjust
for Revenue impacts while giving time to
transition smoothly full repeal in the
second year provides Clarity and
certainty for all stakeholders this
approach ensures we can responsibly
manage the budgetary implications while
moving towards a fairer and more
Equitable tax
structure I urge the committee to
recommend HP 417 for passage and I'm
happy to yield to questions thank
you thank you do we have
questions represent
Aly thank
you I sympathize with you about
communication Services text though I do
not understand how you know
uh about the effect of the complexities
on the the uh large uh corporations that
are paying it at this point it seems to
me that they're doing a pretty good job
of hiding most of the cost that used to
be in the phone
tax uh beforehand could you explain how
you arrived at all this knowledge well
I'm happy to and I certainly don't
pretend to be as well informed about uh
this source of Revenue as I'm sure many
uh folks on this committee are that have
been on this committee for a good while
um I did ask the legislative research
team to get me some information and even
they were unable to turn up as much
information as I might have liked what I
can tell you from my personal experience
uh in dealing with uh Consolidated
Communications is that uh in some cases
uh they explicit ly charge uh this tax
against Services which are data services
that are used exclusively for internet
um and the the reason behind that is a
is a conversation that I've had at
length with their attorneys and and with
others and I use that example not to
single them out as a bad actor I'm
singling them out as an example because
to your point they found it to be
sufficiently complex and sufficiently
different than the billing systems that
they have off the shelf uh for for use
in other states as well um that they
basically turned around to me and said
well you know the the this is a few
years ago the $460 a year uh that I was
paying in New Hampshire communication
Services tax uh we will make you whole
for that by reducing our cost to you uh
but we're still going to render it to
the state because we can't figure out
how to fix it in our systems it's absurd
and and I think what you see is you see
today that there are some people who are
charged for internet services where of
course they're not charge this tax
because the companies know not to charge
it on internet but under the covers uh
those internet service providers are
often having to use Communications links
where they are paying this tax and it
creates this this hidden uh complexity I
think was the word I used and I think
it's a fair word to
use followup good I have a a followup on
this what bothers me is that um there
are several bills that are trying to cut
down different pieces of the revenue
we've got while the revenue is being
reduced Naturally by the end of the
federal stimuli and um wouldn't it be
more logical to cut these Services once
we know what we can can uh reduce the
cost of government to rather than
before so I I imagine this is a an
answer that you hear frequently on this
committee uh and in the finance
committees um my point of view is that
the way to manage a budget is
twofa first of all you should not spend
more than you bring in and second of all
you should be prudent around what you're
spending and I am looking forward this
year to us being exceptionally prudent
with what we're spending uh I defer to
this committee to understand whether or
not we can afford to remedy uh this
concern now uh but I do believe as I
said that uh this
um this Revenue source which has been
trending down for a number of years and
I know it's reported in the fiscal note
is currently $30 million uh was uh $50
million or so only a few years ago uh we
we know that this is not going to be uh
A continuing $30 million per random
Revenue Source anyway um so I I think
the question at hand is do you believe
this is the most appropriate uh way to
need follow up thank you but given that
on nobody is willing to raise a
tax on I think you ought to have a
conversation with your constituents
about what the property tax is doing to
them thank you I I'm well aware of uh
the the property taxes in my towns and I
think the the residents in those towns
would agree with you with with with me
maybe with you I don't want to read into
what you were saying you you you talked
about the the fact that we're not
talking about raising taxes I I I
frankly think that those residents would
not wish to see their property taxes or
any other taxes raised if if we can help
it we should be understanding that
people are having to tighten their belts
at home uh that they have uh cost of
living which is increased uh
dramatically over the last several years
and we should be doing everything in our
power to cut
spending any other uh any other
questions seeing none thank you very
uh thank you Mr chairman to the
committee my name is berie Dees I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association we are a nonpartisan
nonprofit voluntary um membership
organization that each municipality and
city in the state of New Hampshire has
voluntarily uh joined and we represent
their interests here in the legislature
um I am testifying today because the
municipal Association is a pose to House
Bill 417 as currently written we are not
opposed to the communications tax repeal
we have no stance on how the state
raises its revenues or allocates those
revenues as long as it doesn't impact
the aid that municipalities get but
where the revenue comes from we believe
is completely in the purview of the
state we have no position on our only
opposition to this bill as it's
currently written is that um without an
update to RSA 72 8-a the
Telecommunications polls and conduits
under our property tax statutes um the
current
um telecoms companies that are subjected
their line subjected to the
communications tax they are exempt from
property tax we believe that if you are
to repeal the communications tax that
you need to update the property tax
statute so they can be um a part of the
assessed property value in a community
like the electrical industry who's uh
subject to the utility properties tax so
we would kindly um our stance would be
to request the committee make an
amendment to this bill so then when the
repeal is over that these uh that this
real estate um would be treated the way
that the electrical industry is treated
the utilities and um would be subjected
to that tax um and there's also the
issue that we kind of you know our
assessors has raised with us which um is
it could be a constitutional unequal
protection argument because you'll have
the electrical industry running lines
right next to the Telecommunications
industry and one is subjected to
property taxes and the other one is
subjected to no tax and historically the
legislature has argued that the
Telecommunications line should not be
subjected to tax because there is a
Communications um Services tax so with
that I'll um I'll appreciate you guys
hearing my testimony I'll take any
questions representa ORS thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
so do you have any idea I would hope you
do how many properties are we talking
about what's the value of the properties
and what would be the estimated Revenue
to the state so this isn't necessarily
property it is the lines that are along
the telephone polls or the telephone
polls themselves I got that yep um you
would I I I would guess you'd have to
probably ask telecommunication lines
because we don't have any specific
information from the municipality's end
of how much potential assessed property
value exists out there but you know I'd
have to Gander to say it's probably
around the same as how much there is
electrical lines because most of these
telecommunication lines are right next
to the on the same telephone poll is
right next to the electrical lines for
the utility company
so it's probably a lot of assessed value
yep follow up
so the other side of that coin is the
there are buildings and pieces of land
here and there like I see TDS has at
least two or three in the Chai Chester
area so are those properties being
taxed that's a good question of what
property tax or if they're subjected to
adjust a telecommunications tax and I'll
take a note and I'll get back to you on
that yeah we like this is kind of out of
our wheelhouse but we do know that we'd
like any assessed property in the
community to be assessed equally with
other property and especially because
you would be able to burden shift from
the property taxpayers to the
telecommunications companies that
essentially wouldn't be paying a tax
unless you made an update to RSA 72 call
8-a yeah and I would be interested to
know if they're paying BBT or bet tax
or I would guess they are but I'm not
100% sure you'd have to ask Dr but I
would guess because they're a business
they're going to be subjected to that
tax and they makes that tax and they
make enough Revenue but I will check to
see um if they're subjected to you know
regular real estate
taxes representative opal excuse thank
you Mr chairman um and thank you for
taking my question I am sympathetic to
your argument um or
suggestion my question though is my
understanding is there
is excuse
me federal law that bars taxation of
internet access and I'm
wondering we can't tax it under the
communications Services
tax uh I think representative McFarland
talked about the complications there I'm
wondering what the what the federal law
versus if we change if we amend this to
allow Communications companies to be
taxed by
property what impact that might have or
how whether that would conflict with
federal law I'd have to defer to Dr I
mean they would be the ones that because
I know there's specific statutes in the
communication Services tax law that does
explain what is exempt so then it isn't
arai with federal law we don't have a
stance on that currently um I haven't
reviewed those statutes closely follow
up Mr chair um no what I'm asking is Dr
already um says and I think
representative McFarland talked about
this we do not
tax um the communications tax is not a
tax on internet access it is only a tax
essentially on landlines um uh so
federal law bars taxing internet access
the lines that you're talking about were
this were were this bill to be amended
as apparently the municipal Association
would like and again I'm sympathetic to
the argument but I'm wondering ing if
the argument from the utility from the
communications companies would be the
lines that you're prepared to Pro to to
include as a property tax are lines that
provide not just phone service but also
internet access I mean for example in my
situation I have Xfinity whatever
they're calling themselves these days
that that provides both phone
service and my internet access but it's
the same line and I don't know how I
don't know how you'd apply a property
tax to that I'm
just yeah I'm just wondering no that's
an that's an excellent question um
that's the first time that's been raised
to me and I can bring that back to our
team at the municipal
Association um so I'll do some more
research and maybe I can send a letter
to the committee and provide some
clarification on how exactly maybe
exemption language need to be written in
the federal statutes um we just know
that um it's been raised To Us by the
assessors that there's a lot of assessed
value in these land in these lines um
you know the the lines and the the
different telecommunication equipment
and that currently utilities um you know
electrical utilities are subjected to
the tax and it's been common for the
exemption to exist and you know the
justification for that exemption in our
property tax law has been the existence
of um the CST the communication Services
tax so if that goes away we would like
that to come under um assess value in a
community to tax so and I can try to
figure out more about it so we can make
some clarities to make sure we're not
making recommend that run a foul with
federal
law representative Malloy thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question this I think this follows up
with what we're just talking about would
the municipal Association be comfortable
then with uh an increase
uh property tax levy on the utilities
and the uh that would would the
municipal Association be in favor of
that you said you weren't in favor of
the uh the house bill as its r WR but if
if there was an increase burden on
business the the the utilities to pay
this tax would the municipal Association
be in favor of that well the utilities
or you're talking about the util sorry
let me the property tax that they would
be paying if you had the bill change the
way I think I understood what you wanted
to talk about you maybe I didn't
understand it maybe you need to clarify
that yeah I so I can clarify um
currently tell Communications that are
subject to the communication Services
tax are Exempted from the utility's
property tax under um you know and it's
the specific exemption is the last
sentence in RSA 72 8-a we believe if you
get rid of the communication Services
tax that like before the communication
Services tax existed that that those um
telecommunication lines like utility Lin
should be subed to the utility property
tax thank you my my misunderstanding
Thank you for clarifying appreciate it
represent
elme thank
you I think you ought to talk to the
assessing Standards
Board on I believe they're the ones who
have been dealing with this with the
telephone polls and have also been
dealing in general with making
assessments Equitable
across and I think that they did finish
dealing with the telephone polls so they
could give you an answer I appreciate
that and I was planning on we uh we
contact a lot of our assessors and some
who do serve on that board to help with
clarifications but they were also the
ones who raised this concern with us and
also the Constitutional concern which is
not our primary concern we're more
concerned about the um the you know the
potential loss of assess value in a
community um that could decrease a tax
burn under the property
taxpayers it sounds like a fair
okay seeing no more questions thank you
very much thank you that's all I have
for uh Pink cards is there anyone else
oh here comes another one representive
you living in the land of the double
booked right this building is the poster
child for that uh for the record
represent of Steve Pearson Rockingham
District
13 um I'm speaking in opposition to the
repeal of the communications tax
for a more General reason um I have had
the honor of serving on the governor's
transition team and in a meeting
yesterday with the LBA her legal counsel
the chief of staff and the budget writer
um this repeal of the communication tax
was brought up in
conversation um that did not go well
they are extraordinarily concerned about
the loss of revenue from this in order
to create a state budget and I am as
well I I think when we're already
looking at shortfalls in revenue and
projections that are are off if you will
from our prior budget simply
repealing what amounts to almost $30
million seems doesn't seem like a good
idea in these times so um so I I sit
before you in opposition to the repeal
simply out of the sake of being able to
create a a state budget that
works thank you um do we have qu
representative elme yes uh we have
already listened to a bill that was
going to be cutting a tax again does
this cover blanketly or just no I'm
speaking specifically to this to the
and this is one that would actually help
the towns to make up losses that they've
been given from the state I mean how how
that money is used and how that goes
into the state budget is is currently
the purview of the governor's office I
I'm not here to speak to how they want
to do that but you know like I said when
we're looking at when we're looking at
shortfalls here I I just don't think
this is the time to do away with a
Source represent
Opel um representative McFarland
testified and
I'm um I don't have the statistics in
front of me but just recognizing the
fact that
landlines are going the way of telegraph
polls and Pony
Express um and you just referred to this
as a consistent source of Revenue I'm
are you really sure of that it seems
like yeah the numbers have been fairly
consistent over the years it is
regressing it is shrinking but it's it's
not falling off a cliff so we we still
have use of this Revenue source for now
I mean we're looking at a two-year
budget it's a it's a two-year
projection I I understand we're looking
at a two-year projection but you would
agree that the numbers have declined
over time sure thank
you yes represent yeah thank you you
understand there's concern about the
repeal of the tax at this time is there
a concern about a repeal at this tax at
a later time or a phase in
repeal like I said I I've we exist in
twoyear Cycles so I'm I have to look at
the now which is which is
today and and that now includes the
entire cycle of the budget so even
though this might be phased in over two
years uh the position is that you prefer
not to be addressed at all during this
two-year period correct I would prefer
that the communications tax stay exactly
representative shamberg thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative taking
this question you said that um you're an
opposition or the group you're in
discussion with is an opposition to this
this
reduction is there any other information
you could relate to us and what there in
opposition no I on reductions red I will
not speak for them that's their job to
do that and like I said the discussion
was solely around the communic the
repeal of the communications tax um just
just in general questions for the person
uh testifying should stick to the bill
in
question thank you seeing no more
okay is there anyone else who would like
to testify on
HB
4177 seeing none I will close the public
417 and we now
have 15 minutes until the next uh public
1:45 yes May
um
speaker
okay go ahead um is there a protocol for
when we look at the
signin is my question because some
committees actually say how many signed
in which way but now that you can sign
in all day my suggestion would be when
we do the exec maybe somehow the clerk
or someone would say say on this bill 80
signed in for 20 against so cuz I think
we're supposed to record
that um I mean some committees used to
actually hold up the pink sheets well
not the pink sheet the the blue yeah the
yeah the blue sheet yeah and and you're
exactly right the issue is that now they
can sign in all day us to you had to
sign in but maybe if we do it around the
time that we exec at least it's part of
the record that we know how the signin
went yeah is that something you can get
Bill and I think your clerk would be
great at doing that talk to Karen about
I know they have to fill up sheets
somebody has to keep that normally that
would put into the file yeah they keep
it in the folder yeah up to the chair
whether we announced that or not okay
good practice I didn't know if there was
a
protocol it seems fair to the public
yeah but you guys I'm sure you can work
out a system but I mean some committees
really make a big deal about reading the
numbers yeah we'll see what we can
I don't check it off till the first
speaker
goes so I want a free appertizer that's
why it was late did you get one yeah we
got um the arti choke dip yep those good
Rich understand some of the the chairs
don't necessarily think
that well um they don't pay anything
people people don't pay any attention to
it I mean I've heard people say oh
they're out of state
or so they don't care especially on
things like um Universal
vouchers I mean it like thousands to you
right
e
okay we are back and time is
1:46 and
I'll open in the public hearing on HB
596 and we'll invite
uh representative TIY
up um is representative T okay you're
okay do I have a
um do I have a card for
you yes oh Paige here it is okay thank
you
good afternoon everyone uh thank you for
your time today uh here today to
introduce House Bill
596 um and if if you were a
representative from the North
country or really any tourism driven
area in the state of New
Hampshire you've likely had a
constituent approach you and ask what
seems like a really innocent question
which is how much meals and rooms
revenue is collected in our
town that seems like it should be a
pretty simple
question what happens next is a journey
down a rabbit
hole searching for this data which
you'll eventually learn quite simply
doesn't
exist and why is
that so our current meals and rooms
reporting practices do not require
operators to report the municipality
where receipts were
collected the data simply doesn't
exist and additionally we allow
operators with facilities in multiple
municipalities to consolidate receipts
under a single Master license
attributing all their revenues received
to a single
County so receipts collected in one
County are frequently reported in
another leaving the public with no reli
ible way to understand where the revenue
originates and in other words we have an
incomplete picture of where the revenue
comes
from and those reports which are made
available actually share misleading data
attributing this Revenue received in one
County to
another if you're like me who comes from
a management background in the private
sector this is a really surprising
discovery you know imagine running your
business and not knowing where your
Revenue comes from how do you plan how
do you invest how do you allocate
resources effectively and this is the
same untenable situation that we face in
the state of New Hampshire and HB 596
seeks to remedy
that so at its core this bill this bill
intends to uphold the principles of
government transparency and
accountability by ensuring that meals
and rooms tax revenues are tracked and
reported at the municipal
level in my opinion transparency
shouldn't just be a bureaucratic
ideal but we should look at it as a
Cornerstone of public
Trust And while I am far from the first
representative to tell a shocked constit
consent asking about this question that
the state of New Hampshire will not make
this data available to them I hope to be
the last it just seems like this is a
question we should be able to answer for
our
constituents taxpayers have a right to
know how and where their money is
generated and used and just as a
business owner relies on accurate
Revenue data to make informed decisions
our state our towns and our local
tourism organizations need precise
information to measure the impact of
effectively the granular reporting that
this bill would allow will help us to
paint that clearer picture of which
communities are driving tourism related
income additionally this level of
specificity will make it easier to
identify emerging Trends and adapt
quickly to grow grow opportunities
ensuring a more targeted and impactful
approach to strengthening our local
economies among those who will benefit
from the longitudinal data set this
reporting would create are our towns
themselves our tourism related
nonprofits and even our state division
of travel and tourism this is data that
will be valuable to
all so how do we achieve these goals
this bill makes two targeted changes to
current
statute first it requires the Dr to
update its reporting forms so that
operators include the municipality where
receipts were collected in addition to
the total revenues and we could still do
this on a Consolidated
form second to address privacy concerns
in smaller communities with very few
operators which I take seriously the
bill includes a narrow exemption to
confidential rules the Dr the Dr will
disclose Municipal Revenue data only for
communities with 10 or more operators
ensuring taxpayer privacy while still
providing accurate and useful data
wherever
possible by requiring the Dr to collect
and disclose aggregated tax data by
municipality while protecting taxpayer
privacy in smaller communities this bill
balances the need for public access to
data with reasonable confidentiality
protections it's my goal that HB 596
would Empower towns tourism
organizations and the state's division
of travel and tourism to make datadriven
decisions that strengthen infrastructure
attract visitors and boost local
economies all while giving our
constituents confidence in how revenues
are managed and I'm happy to take your
questions I'm I'm also um happy to turn
it over anytime to my colleague rep
Tierney who we have a a large number of
co-signers uh on a letter on this bill
that I'm looking forward to him
sharing R ORS thank you Mr chairman
thanks for taking my question so is
there a problem in your opinion with the
revenue being collected and not being
reported being withheld by a business or
is this beyond that
can you repeat the question I'm not
quite sure I understand yeah I I wasn't
quite sure if there's a a reporting
requirement that's not you know business
are collecting the taxes but not re not
retaining them and giving them to the
state they're so I I wasn't sure if it
was that and or
more that's not that's not my goal that
may be something this committee may be
concerned with but it's not what this
bill deals with this bill is strictly
about ensuring that when these revenues
are reported that we understand where
they were collected which is currently
simply not the case um we both don't
know the municipality where they were
collected but we also often have
incorrect data about the county in which
they were corrected you can be you can
be an operator with 10 facilities across
the state you could have nine of those
facilities in Coos but report them all
out of Grafton right so we the the data
we get is very misleading and the data
that the public receives and is relying
Opel um I understand this is not the
intent of the bill but I'm wondering
what assurances you might give
particularly smaller
communities um while I certainly would
agree that it's good management to
understand where your revenue is coming
from and where your expenditures are no
matter where it
is um could this not be a first step
toward some communi saying hey we're
doing twice the amount of rooms and
meals tax as our neighbor we should be
getting a larger share back and thus
punishing communities who may not have
the natural resources the mountains or
the ocean or whatever um and and wind up
in a situation where we're pitting
neighbor against neighbor sure I guess
my answer to that
is this is a little bit of a copout but
it's a question for another day um I
think the the question on my mind is
should the data be available do does the
public and do those towns people
regardless of what they feel once they
have the data deserve to have access to
that information I will say coming from
a rural tourist Community I certainly am
going to advocate for for additional
Revenue solutions for my town but what I
see as the revenue solution may be
different than what my co-sponsor
Senator Ros for sees or what another
person sees is the appropriate solution
so I would say we need the data and I
hope that we can agree that that we need
the data and the public deserves the
data and then we all do need to come
back for a separate conversation about
how do we ensure that small towns have
the resources they need and the revenues
they need but I'm not advocating here
okay seeing no more questions thank you
Tierney good afternoon Mr chairman and
uh
Representatives okay I'm not a
co-sponsor of this bill but I've been
asked by the Coos delegation to read a
letter uh that they have all jointly
signed uh dear committee chair and
members the letter requests the
committee to support HB 596 relative to
reporting requirements for entities that
collect meals and rooms
taxes uh change the next couple of words
to say the Coos County delegation
unanimously supports this bill our
district Senator Dave roachford is a
co-sponsor of the bill given the
substantial impact turm has on our
region and it is substantial it is
essential to consider the benefits of
identifying these taxes at the municipal
level as opposed to countywide our
Region's tourism sector is vibrant and
healthy and highly concentrated in
specific municipalities each
contributing differently to the overall
tourism landscape by quantifying meals
and room taxes at the municipal level we
can achieve more accurate meaningful
data on where tourism res revenues are
being generated and how budgetary
decisions can best support these
impacted communities below are several
important benefits of quantifying these
taxes on a municipal scale accurate
Revenue attribution quantifying meals
and rooms taxes at the municipal level
allows for a more precise allocation of
tax revenue directly correlating it with
the specific localities that generate it
this enables municipalities to track
exactly how much tourism Revenue they
are producing as opposed to relying on
countywide averages that may obscure the
true economic impact within each
individual municipality improve tax
forecasting and budgeting by collecting
and quantifying tax data at the
municipal level local governments can
develop a more accurate forecast for
future Revenue opportunities this
enhances their ability to plan and
budget effectively ensuring the
resources are directed toward the most
impactful area such as infrastructure
improvements local tourism Market Mar
initiatives and community services that
benefit both residents and visitors
ident identifying Trends and growth
areas when tax data is Quantified at the
municipal level it becomes easier to
identify emerging Trends and areas of
growth within specific communities for
example if one municipality experiences
a spike in tourism due to a new
attraction or event they can quickly
adapt by reallocating resources or
adjusting services to meet increased
demand something that would be difficult
to pinpoint with countywide data
alone okay enhancing local tourism
strategies with more granular data
municipalities can tailor their tourism
Investments more effectively this level
of granularity also helps in measuring
the effectiveness of Tourism related
programs and initiatives optimizing
local economic impact quantifying tax
revenues at the municipal level provides
a clearer picture of the economic
contributions made by tourism to each
local economy this enables
municipalities to measure the return on
investment for tourism related
expenditures more accurately and make
adjustments that maximize economic
benefits for their residents and
businesses fostering accountability and
transparency by tracking meals and room
tax revenues at the municipal level the
state can ensure greater transparency
and
accountability regarding the fiscal note
we would like to formally note that the
$50,000 fiscal impact for each for such
an improvement appears rather excessive
considering the minor technical change
required in the system even if the cost
is near this amount the return on
investment for 13 cities and 221 towns
would amount to just
$214 per Community which seems like an
excellent value in conclusion the
ability to qualify to quantify meals and
rooms taxes at the municipal level
provides local governments with the
tools to make more informed data-driven
decisions it ensures that the revenue
generated from tourism is tracked
accurately and used efficiently
ultimately benefiting the local economy
enhancing the quality of services
provided by both residents and visitors
uh thank you for your consideration of
the matter I would be happy to further
discuss the potential benefits of
quantifying Tourism related taxes at the
municipal level and how this approach
could positively impact our region and
it's signed by rep Davis which is uh
coos two Mike uh wette which is Coos 3
myself and the and representative Durkin
who are Coos one representative King
who's Coos 4 representative Murphy who's
Coos 6 and then representative coren
valerino and morancy who are all Coos uh
five and
seven and with that thank you you want I
will take any questions if you've got
them got a lot of good ones for
you I think does does anyone have any
questions actually since no one has any
question I do have one question that was
swirling around my mind is I'm listening
to all this testimony and that
is the whole point is to get data for
municipalities uh cities you know
whatever on an individualized basis but
doesn't each municipality know they know
how many restaurants they have in town
they know how many uh hotels they have
in town uh planning boards planning
board members typically have a really
good feel for how things are going um it
just seems to me that individual towns
because I know one of the concerns was
if a town has 10 or fewer establishments
then um you know they would be exempt
from this
but at the end of the day it's not like
I mean in my mind I'm just think just
thinking as I'm talking that it would
seem like each municipality or city they
know exactly what they've got in their
cities and towns and um they can make
decisions based on how much traffic they
have going to these
establishments correct they can but the
problem they've got is uh my town for
example we don't have 10 entities we'd
be we wouldn't get the
information um but uh other ones do and
their question question is it goes back
to what I call the nonsense that was
created with swept donor
towns any tax you can think of income
sales doesn't make any difference swept
there's a donor in every single one of
them be it a wealthy community sends
more income tax in or a community that's
got a whole bunch of stores there's
contributing more sales
tax other ones don't contribute as much
so everything has a donor Town we're not
looking to find out who's a donor Town
what they're looking for is to find out
how much that town is bringing into the
area in regards to how much they're also
getting back then maybe they yeah they'd
ask for it or do we throw more money
into that because this was asked for by
our uh economic uh development adviser
for the county she's the one who uh
requested the bill be put in and she's
the one who G up this letter that the
nine of us signed she's looking for the
information to find out where do we
concentrate our uh monies that we're
investing in the uh County or in the
municipalities where do they go which
one are we getting the better uh bang
for the
buck that's what she's looking for okay
uh represent
ol the way I understand it each
Community receives a check or transfer
for funds yep correct
um
routinely they have a record going back
years as to how much they make they know
that if a
new um restaurant opens
up then there should be an increase and
if there isn't then somebody's
restaurant failed and somebody's
didn't by the way don't go into the
restaurant business a lot of them fail
yes
but the information is there if you look
for it you've got a history of how much
is coming in and it's not just how much
is coming in from the town or to the or
from the town and then going back to the
town but it also has to deal with what
the overall economic environment is so
having to specify this out to me and I
sit on the planning board in my
town
unimportant because you have to deal
with the entire operation not just how
much is coming in from the
MWR
it it's it's
just unimportant data is that because
yeah I'm going to say it's one we were
told not to ask
would you
believe it it may be unimportant to the
planning board side of the house or but
to the economic development side of the
house um they seem to want the
information and all we're attempting
with this is to get it for them when we
get meals and rooms taxes and I'm on the
select board in Northland okay we get a
single check and if I remember correctly
it comes once a year towards the end of
the year it's not I don't think it's a
month
transfer and uh so we get our
check um how much of that came from
the I think it's three hotels we've got
in town
motels uh versus uh how many for the
four or five restaurants that we've got
in town uh nobody knows which restaurant
is doing well which restaurant is doing
bad okay uh with the size of Northland
you can tell by how many cars are in the
parking lot you usually but is that
because the cook is not up to standards
or do they have the wrong type of uh
Cuisine that they're offering in other
words are they tie and nobody up in that
neck of the wood say wants it don't know
uh and that information isn't going to
necessarily be in there well it would be
in there because we'd be getting it by
uh restaurant so this one's failing for
this reason that one's failing for that
reason it just gives the economic
development folks the ability to figure
out what way to look at it do we need
more fried chicken places versus do we
need uh more Korean
ones follow
up is it the job of the community to go
out and select and pick and choose what
they need or just say here we are if you
want to come here come here if you don't
that's your choice but is it the job of
the community to go out and pick and
choose what restaurant they want to have
in town or what motel chain they want to
town not the community but the economic
development yes because if they can tell
you that this restaurant or that type
hotel is going to do better wouldn't you
rather invest and put that one up than
uh the
other representative
Bolton would you believe that I agree
with both representative and our chair
and um I just have a question like maybe
the the one benefit that might come out
of this probably can't because I
understand that um if it's a um provider
that has multiple facilities in
different towns they might have an
aggregate um you know transmission other
you know M&R to uh excuse me Dr but um
representative we we can't excuse me
yeah we can't hear you I'm sorry okay
which part did you miss me agreeing with
chair so um I I just think the one thing
that I might conceive of as a value as
being um a select board member in town
of Plymouth is um more granular
reporting but apparently that's that
can't happen or doesn't happen you know
we have um you know Alex Ray uh has two
facilities in Plymouth and a hotel but
he ALS I don't know how he Aggregates
his uh revenues um of all the things he
has but that might be of value and I'm
not certain if uh if this can be met um
I don't know if you're aware of that or
maybe Dr could let us know no I know it
it took uh uh the folks up at the County
uh about a week to finally get reports
out of Dr that just told them okay
here's how much meals tax you got and
here's how much rooms tax you got
but not what communities it came from
just how much the county got uh and or
actually how much the county collected
and paid in uh from it what ones came
from there they'd like it broken out by
municipality to assist them and my
daughter works for the common man and I
believe they've got 10 or 12 restaurants
here in the state spread all over the
place so where he puts them out from I
don't know either follow follow up so
why couldn't it be maybe it's a question
for Dr obviously but why couldn't it be
broken up into um you know more granular
level uh not countywide but maybe
townwide I have a sneaking suspicion
from the bill and in talking with some
of the others that the reason for this
is Dr won't do it unless they're told to
it representative Southworth uh thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question which is kind of broad um I
should have this memorized I think I do
but my understanding was that the meals
and rooms tax is collected again with
these problems you've mentioned but it's
given out per capita it really has
nothing to do if you have if you have no
restaurants in your town you get you
know meals and rooms and if you have the
most restaurants in the whole Sea Coast
you don't get so so some of what we've
said got a little bit off I think
because it has nothing to do with what
you have in your town to get meals and
rooms money and someone's talking about
the select when people can look at how
much you get each year you can and you
can see if it went up or down from the
State but has nothing to do with your
businesses at all um so I think your
bill is very important um I think that
would be useful data for lots of things
in fact here on this committee we've
been interested in this data for 10
years that I've been here but anyway
thank you thank you
yes representative thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question to get
even more specific about this and Dr is
here if I recall this committee has been
told that by getting very granular with
this in terms of knowing what restaurant
is doing what and their sales here their
hotel sales there would provide
competitive information to uh uh their
competitors and then people would find
out just exactly how much of a
restaurant is making how much he's
losing so on and so forth so that's been
from what I've recalled that's been a a
position that the Dr has explained to us
in terms of confidentiality and
businesses and tax collection Dr is here
and perhaps they can address that again
but that's my would you believe that's
my understanding I'm sorry sorry thank
you sorry well like I said our town
wouldn't even get it the information
simply because we don't have enough of
10 May I follow up well my my question
Still Remains would you believe that if
this was released there would be
competitive information wherever you are
in in Portsmouth or Keen or conquered
that demonstrates to the competitors
what your particular restaurant or hotel
is making and that would be a
disadvantage to the owner that might be
a disadvantage and and if that were the
case then I could see where um this
could become
uh not subject to a
91a so that the town wouldn't have to
give the information out to anybody but
the one who came in and asked about
their particular restaurant and they
should know the information themselves
anyway but it would not be subject to a
91a
request so it would simply
stay with the board of Selectmen a town
manager Town Administrator whatever and
around okay representative ducet yeah
and thank you Mr chairman to to
accentuate the point at least the way I
I read this it's talking about reporting
from the municipality not from
Individual businesses yeah individual
Enders so I can see in a smaller
situation where it was
11 uh people that paid into you might be
able to do that but I I don't know that
that argument holds water in at least
legislation okay thank thank you next up
thank you representative
duet
on I would ask to talk about the
confidentiality part of this first uh
it's the only thing that anybody but the
Dr would see would be aggregations of
the
uh the revenues
from uh over
10 from 10 or more uh uh restaurants or
hotels and hotels so it would not
provide it might provide somebody who
was creating a chain from
Nashua uh to decide that gee I want to
go put one in Lebanon and I want to go
put one in in uh
sale them but uh because they seem to be
doing quite a lot of
business um but it would not provide
enough information for any kind of
competitive Advantage otherwise that I
can think of um what I wanted to do was
expand this a little bit because it is
not just
tourism it is as some people were saying
Economic
Development and how how you chart the
different towns chart their courses
depending on what
um what resources they've got relative
to other places but
also uh a question of fairness that the
in
the the restaurant and hotel business is
spread
out uh highly unequally around the state
and it concentrates in the
largest uh population areas but it also
concentrates in the middle-sized towns
that are hubs for a very large area
Lebanon is a
metropolis uh uh what do you call
micropolis of a 100,000
people of whom at this point we're
rapidly growing 16,000 and uh live in
Lebanon and sleep there but everybody
else about I think probably half of them
come in Daily to
work um they stay afterwards they get
drunk they run into each other's
cars uh they they start fires they screw
up the plumbing they do all sorts of
things that the town then has to deal
with with um and and then they go home
and they have a child that has mental
health issues child comes to Lebanon
they have
uh homeless people that can't figure out
what to do they come to
Lebanon um
and on they they so they're the also the
hub for a lot of Social Services which
and representative Bolton can tell you
uh are usually tax exempt uh from
property tax for good reason
um we have the largest uh Regional
thrift store in our region uh and huge
numbers of people are coming to it now
and and the money from that thrift store
goes to helping all of those people that
are looking for for monit AR
Assistance or or assistance with how to
turn their lives around which is given
without money except for the salaries so
um the
hubs get per population just like
everybody else but the hubs have a lot
more costs than anybody
else and for us to turn around and try
to ruce ourselves to having a police
department the size per capita that
everybody else in our sector of Grafton
County does um would create a major
crime
wave because we need three times that in
order to keep up with all of the
accidents that happened and people that
fight with each other and people that
are caught with methane lab methadone
labs things like that
uh
and on this is not just lean and
obviously it's a lot of smaller Urban
hubs around the state that are
struggling to deal with the fact that
the property tax
becomes considerably inequitable and one
of the things that it is in involved
with it
is um that the meals and rooms tax which
is found primarily in those those hubs
and in the large
cities
um is um distributed per capita so I
know this this is an issue that probably
we lose because we um there are an aw I
think probably more people in the
legislature that are from small small
towns and our bedroom
communities uh or or um retirement
communities than there are working
communities but we have two of the
largest companies in the world based in
Lebanon and we have a lot of other
businesses that grow up in Lebanon and
stay in Lebanon and we need more help
with economic development so that we can
afford to keep these going without
having a major tax
revote and I think that it would help to
know that I I forget I have no idea how
many we've got it now now I think it's
about 20 25 restaurants inside lean and
but it's probably it may be 40 uh plus
food
trucks so I don't know how you address a
but I think that the issue is really
important and that the reporting is
really the first step towards trying to
figure out how you make this work
so that
was will you take questions
representative
YY thank you representative for taking
my question or questions I have two the
first question is where in this bill is
there anything about confidentiality of
the of the aggregated funds information
so that it it doesn't become part of the
public
record in the town so that the anybody
can come up and start taking a look at
their various uh uh restaurant or uh
Motel businesses to see what's going on
I thought I remembered seeing this in
second I do know that this is a strict
it looks like it isn't in there but I do
know that this is a strict uh rule of
the Department of Revenue Administration
that they shall not release the Nam the
numbers of anything that is less than
10 I yes we both know that uh and I
would just wanted to point that out that
it's not here oh specific question uh
the other question I have is it seems as
though this bill is putting a burden on
the various taxpayers to come up with
another set of forms another set of
accounting
another is that cost taken into
consideration a cost of the
business is that taken into
consideration I don't believe it is I
believe it' be a little a little bit of
difficulty to set up uh I'd like to uh
mention that representative of
brami uh lives in a town which has no
restaurant or at least it did when he
was telling us this and they had uh on
the books they had nine restaurants in
that town because uh the owner of those
nine restaurants lived in that town
yeah some of those are big chains and on
the main road there um yeah I thank you
thanks anybody else yes represent
opal thank you Mr chairman
um representative Amy I expressed my
concern before to you personally but
um and Mr chairman give me just a little
bit of leeway I'm going to talk about
sitting here for the last few weeks
listening to all of the
legislation uh representing three small
towns um in a school district that is
struggling um in a state
where the quality of your education
depends very much on your ZIP
code which is kind of arbitrary and not
really relative to whether you deserve a
quality education and
now my fear
is that we're going in the same
direction potentially or at least we're
opening the
door um to begin to reward those
communities that have been blessed
with
wonderful opportunities for tourism and
great natural
beauty and communities that maybe aren't
quite so
blessed potentially will be again short
short
changed
[Music]
um I don't know whether there's
something you can offer or the other
sponsors of this can offer that would
reassure
me but I'll also say I sit on my Town's
planning board and I chair our economic
development
committee and I would ask you would you
believe that I have a very good sense of
which of the four restaurants in our
town are doing well and which are not
and
why so I I'm sorry Mr chairman I think I
asked two questions there well I
actually it was interesting what you
just said because that was part of my
premise when I was talking earlier that
planning boards and and certainly
Economic Development boards within towns
know what's going on so I'm I'm I'm
still not sure I completely understand
the
the need for this yeah I will say as a
representative from a hub Urban Hub
which is at this point growing beyond
our
capacity and is been sparking tax
revolts that we hadn't seen for a long
time um it is on we we cannot control
what is going on
in representative opal's town or in St
Johnsbury where some of our people that
work daily in our place come from in
Vermont on but we are the
recipient of influxes of people that
work in our area that that eat in our
area area that
on
on get snowbound sometimes in our area
um that come for the hospital which is
the major Hospital in in Northern New
England and
come for
um come to deal drugs in in our
malls and I occasionally come to write
nasty things on our windshields in our
malls
uh and on in general um we have three
times the police that and more fire and
especially more EMTs than we would need
if those those people weren't coming in
and uh it's very difficult to figure
out how to plan for that when you're
working only with the property taxes of
the of the individual town or city so
let me let me just ask you this this the
point of this bill is to gather data
correct just to gather data to try to
figure that out but you're talking as
though that then you'll have more money
to do something with it but this is data
only so where's that money coming from
that is that is the question to be to be
looked at
is how can we get more money into these
centers this the biggest cities do get I
think some federal help and various
other kinds of help that we don't get
but
the the smaller ones are are struggling
increasingly I think and the question is
just how much data can we get that is
going to help
us figure out
strategies representative said Thank you
Mr chairman maybe representative Aly you
can correct me I'm not suggesting I'm
leaning one way or another on this but
the way this reads to me it doesn't
speak to any specifics about how how
revenues are distributed after the fact
the way this reads to me is it's not
specific The Operators themselves
report when paying their taxes what city
or town that those taxes were paid
in that is with the
Dr they're not Distributing that out for
report
specifically by vendor or retailer or
whatever so the way I see this and
correct me if I'm wrong I I read this as
some transparency in reporting a little
deeper level of
transparency town a brought in $1
million Town B brought in $2 million
that's the extent of this and you can
list the towns out but I don't see any
development benefit or anything like
that that's not what I'm reading here so
I
guess am I wrong in the way I'm reading
this is you know reporting transparency
once the information is available at the
Dr in a form that the Dr would be
willing to provide
it it it
does help us to some extent but I agree
it's just the first very first step that
we've never been able to get
over okay um did you have
something okay thank you represent Al me
I'm sorry oh I'm sorry I have had on
quite a while representative Southworth
um partly a point of order I think it's
best looked at as a data bill which is
kind of how it started 20 minutes ago I
think how someone might use the data in
the future isn't really relevant to
supporting the bill the bill is do we
think the data would be useful for our
committee and for other communities as
they want to use it but I don't think we
need to get into how they might use it
but I kind of agree with what you said I
mean the wording is that it's a data
bill yeah I'd be curious from Dr what
the confidentiality is with that
reporting yeah okay thank you represent
all me um I do have before I call Dr up
Tibido good afternoon
my
please uh Kyle Tibido Conway New
Hampshire uh sit on the board of
Selectmen um I guess I am going to be
very brief because fortunately for all
of us pretty much everything I had on my
list has already been said um I I I will
say that uh I think that it the the
focus does at this point in time uh and
I I agree with representative ducet that
the focus needs to be on the
transparency of the collection process
uh I I think we're getting the C in
front of the Horse by trying to say that
we're going to look at redistribution or
or however that might turn out down the
road um there are a lot of things that
the state would be able to use this
information for if they knew exactly
where these funds were coming from uh
let's say for instance uh town of Conway
uh generates X number of millions of
dollars in Mills and rooms tax they
might want to take a look at that
situation and say okay they've got
37,000 people on any given weekend in
the town of Conway maybe we need to
improve our infrastructure for access to
the town of Conway you might be able to
use that information for things of that
nature um I do know uh that we do need
uh additional help based on uh the fact
that we are probably the third maybe
fourth largest tourist area in the state
of New Hampshire uh while it is a
blessing that we have all of those
mountains rivers and Lakes Etc um it it
is also a curse that uh like Lebanon uh
we end up with a situation where we have
double the amount of fire apparatus that
we need and triple the uh the police
department but I think that's a
conversation for a later day I I think
now the the important focus should be on
the
transparency of where this money comes
from and it's been said I'll say it
again rule number one if you're in
business and I've been in business for
44 years you need to know your Revenue
stream you need to know your Revenue
stream in detail where it comes from and
how it got there um I sent an email to
Governor shuno a year ago March um I'm
not going to read the whole thing and
I'm not going to out paraphrase the
majority of it he sent it over to James
Jerry uh budget director State of New
Hampshire I got some information from Mr
Jerry um I asked the pointed question
about if you don't know where that money
is coming from how do you know that it's
being properly and appropriately
collected and accounted for and the
answer was that we have an aggressive
auditing system well your auditing
system can be as aggressive if as it
wants to be but if you can't pinpoint
where the money comes from then what
triggers the audit do you just randomly
pull names out of a hat to say I think
it's time we audit soand so uh or we
ought to audit these businesses over
here in Berlin or we audit these
businesses down here in Manchester uh if
you had a more detailed and it doesn't
have to be detailed to the point where
it becomes onerous on the reporter uh it
it only has to be detailed by uh
geographic location of the physical
collection Point uh if you had that
information and you could install
certain red flags and trips into your
software that would allow uh people to
say oh wait a minute uh in Conway New
Hampshire they collected X number of
dollars in rest France last year and all
of a sudden uh we down several $100,000
in revenues maybe we need to take a look
at what's going on in colway New
Hampshire uh I I don't think you have
that ability today um and if nothing
else I think just for the sake of the
State uh upholding its its pledge to be
a transparent government I think that
the uh the municipalities not
necessarily the public at lodge but at
least the people who run municipalities
the selectman uh Town managers uh um
planning boards Etc should be able to
access this information to have uh more
than a vague idea of what's going on in
that town um the it was brought up that
if you sit on a planning board you're on
a board select you should know what's
going on in town well you should but we
have something in the neighborhood of
3,000 rooms 900 short-term rentals and 6
five restaurants in the town of Conway
it is absolutely physically impossible
for one small fiveman board to keep
track of any of this so if we had this
information it would allow us to make
certain adjustments in how it is that we
do things uh to take a better look a how
to look at some of the situations that
may or may not exist within the town of
Conway to be able to better plan better
prepare uh things of that nature
um most everything else I guess is been
hashed over tonight so I won't take any
more of your time I thank you for your
time thank you do we have questions
represent
opal uh sir I'm fully in support of
transparency and I I frankly believe as
representative Al me talked about there
are a lot of issues certainly in my area
that could be addressed with a more
Regional approach or a more Statewide
approach um but I will point out I think
it was representative Tierney who
brought us the letter uh from the Coos
delegation and point number one says
quantifying meals and rooms taxes at the
municipal level allows for a more
precise allocation of tax revenue
directly correlating it with the
specific local localities that
generate
now would you believe I I find that very
specifically saying we want the data and
then when we have the data we're going
to make the argument that communities
that generate more tourism revenue or
meals and rooms Revenue should get more
of the of the revenue well that that is
a distinct possibility um as I said
Conway is is kind of an anomaly I I
don't think that there are more than
four or five areas within uh the state
of New Hampshire that fall within uh the
uh tourist related uh problems that we
have um there are a lot of them uh
um you have a static population of
10,300 people and that is how the rooms
and males tax today is distributed based
on that static population any given
weekend any given vacation week we have
35,000 people in town uh we have a
police department that's uh two and a
half times the size of any other town
that has a static population of 10,000
people Emergency Services is two to
three times as large um our water and
sore departments are uh taxed uh
severely uh our infrastructure is being
abused on a regular basis so would we
ask for more money at some point in time
I don't know but step one is to find out
where that money comes from and at some
point uh it should become a little bit
more proportional uh in my
opinion so I don't yeah thank you Mr
chairman I I don't disagree with you
just as I don't disagree with
representative Aly um what I do believe
what I'm concerned about is pitting one
town against another town when the
entire state gets a benefit from tourism
in the Conway area the entire State
frankly certainly the region gets a
benefit from what Lebanon does the
entire state gets a benefit from some of
these tourism and and Municipal hubs um
what I'm afraid of would you
believe is the idea of pitting one town
against another so that Conway gets an
decrease yeah this may be something that
we have to discuss during a work
session um thank you very much for your
testimony thank you uh lastly I'll
thank
you good afternoon Jennifer Ramsey tax
policy Council for the Department of
Revenue
Administration lots of questions um
would it be helpful if I if I provided
just a brief um overview I I have heard
a lot of of what I think may be some
misconceptions about how the tax works
and what uh information the department
collects and um if you'd like me too I
could just give a minute or two on that
yeah that sounds good and then we'll go
from there thank you um so remember from
the presentation on the 21st the meals
and rooms tax is a tax on the consumer
of the meal or the room uh or the
vehicle rle and uh operators of those
businesses uh get a license from Dr and
they are the tax collector for the State
uh so each operator files a return with
us monthly um and those operators are
the people who we would audit um in the
case of uh a concern about whether or
not they're paying an appropriate amount
they retain a 3% commission provided
that they file using our electronic
portal and that they file on time and
that they remit the right amount of tax
with their return
um this group of operators ranges from
very sophisticated to Not So
Sophisticated um it's a significant part
of our call center volume is is uh
assisting these taxpayers with with uh
getting their forms into us the correct
way
um we do have uh as representative paig
said people that file on a Consolidated
basis um so if an operator has locations
in 10 15 places within the state of New
Hampshire um they will pick a single
location we call that a master license
under our rules and they will report all
the revenue for their Collective
businesses using that one location uh
they uh may also be out of state um
operators in the case of um large
National chains um also are room rental
facilitators and so some operators don't
even have a c a New Hampshire County um
so to get to the questions about
confidentiality under RSA 21
j14 um the department has a
long-standing policy of not reporting
information that would um potentially
identify a taxpayer and their liability
and we interpret that to mean for data
at the state level
um we do not report a piece of data that
is the aggregate of less than 10
taxpayers and at the local level um that
limit is 20
taxpayers um so the information that
this bill would have us um provide is
not something that we currently have
because we do not ask the operators of
the businesses that file on a combined
basis to tell us what town
the meal was consumed in or the room is
located in they have that information
and we can get to it if we audit but
it's not something that we routinely
collect we could collect that
information um it would require us to
develop a new and much more detailed
form uh We've looked at what some other
jurisdictions use for forms um we would
essentially need to have a line for each
town and have operators fill in the town
uh where the revenue was generated the
amount as well as the number of
businesses in that town if we created
that much more complicated tax form um
we could then gather the information
that is sought by this bill and reported
out um the cost to do that uh I heard a
comment that $50,000 seemed like a lot
of money the reason that that expense is
what it is is because we have to have a
paper form and that paper form has to go
through our very high-speed scanner and
we have to work with a vendor to test to
develop and then test that form and make
sure that it would capture every single
one of those four or 500 Blanks on that
much more complex tax form accurately
and put that into our data system um I
don't know if that was all of the
questions but but maybe a good point to
stop thank you representative du set and
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I think you answered
though at present someone can't go to Dr
and request the receipts of a
specific uh taxpayer that's correct we
would not ever
disclose not change that I'm sorry
obviously if this were to be uh passed
as written it wouldn't change that
that's a different it's not a 91a thing
or anything like that right we have our
a very specific uh RSA 21 j14 is our
statute we are also subject to 91a but
um the tax statute is a little bit
broader protection so we typically look
to that and if I'm interpreting this
bill correctly then um we would still
not be required to provide a specific
taxpayers information but we would
provide aggregated by Town information
so long as there were more than 10 data
points within that or operators within
that town
representative Southworth uh thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um kind of of another one
attached so um if Jones Hardware has a
store in Portsmouth and a store in Salem
uh and a store in Plymouth um and they
send in that information uh there's no
way uh an outside person can compare
those three
Stores um well if they were paying u ms
and reyolds tax um then they would
report that information using a master
license and um the they know the three
but no one else could get that
information correct well our Auditors
could if we needed to but but it's it's
not a part of the tax form that they
send in and is your request uh I mean
I'm requesting can you say again the cut
offs for confidentiality because several
people asked about that yes at the state
level when the data is aggregated at the
state level um we will not disclose
anything with 10 or fewer taxpayers at
any level below the state so county or
city or or town um it's 20 tax pairs
thank
you so this bill actually says 10 so you
would probably want that to say 20 um to
be consistent with our existing policy I
think that would be prudent but it it we
would follow whatever the law was that
that that was
established anybody
else okay okay seeing none thank you
very much thank
you I will close the public hearing on
HB
[Music]
underne
right
Qui
thank
you you gave me extra copies Bill Bill
here's
being 25
53 I'll open the public hearing on HB
540 and recognize representative om
thank you Mr chairman representative
Bill M from City of nashwa Hillsboro
10 speaking to House Bill 540 relative
to the horse racing licenses for large
second I'd like to start by talking
about our current situation with the
large casinos that we uh have and are
possible to have in New Hampshire based
on current law and I Define a large
Casino as a property with over 1,000
machines we have a situation where we
have 14 chable gaming properties with
licenses for historic racing
machines and these are very popular
licenses uh they're so popular that the
smaller mom and pop gambling operations
are now being purchased by larger
entities for major
expansions for example here in the city
of nasua where I live we're about to
have the Lars uh Casino The
Edge um I'm sorry the Nash thank you uh
being developed at the former Sears
property and that's about to open next
month month and expected to have well
over a thousand machines and be a very
entertainment so what's the
problem well we've been very generous
with the licensing of these large
casinos if you wanted a
uh terrible gaming license in the past
that's a very modest fee as it should be
if you had a card room with a couple of
tables 250 bucks for a license
fee um and we had a very successful
terrible gaming operations that we still
do but under current
law
uh operators are committed to sell that
business to a larger
partner and the larger partner is
allowed
to decide if that site's appropriate for
them and if it's not appropriate in
terms of size and opportunity they're
allowed to move that location to another
location within that jurisdiction so for
example in Nashville we've had a couple
of small tural casinos we had the river
and we've had the uh uh lucky
moose they've morphed from uh from card
games into historic racing machines with
their HHR licenses these have been
bought out Delaware North and E
entertainment in particular and now
these properties are being relocated to
much larger
venues the one I mentioned previously
the Sears venue is about to open next
month and the other
property uh owned by Del North is the
former Sheran Tara on exit W NASA and I
believe the intention there is to
convert the hotel into a hotel casino
with the license for historic gaming as
being the main driver for that
opportunity so what's the profitability
of these uh
machines and what's the cost to get a
license well one of the
handouts uh in title of Massachusetts
gives you a point of reference for what
other jurisdictions are looking at for
large
casinos if you want to place a large
Casino in Massachusetts such as the
encor downtown Everett next to Boston or
the MTM
Springfield or the plane view uh former
horse track it's a very serious uh
opportunity and a very serious license
fee for example the Everett casino and
the Springfield casinos have a initial
million that compares to a 20 50 license
fee for similar property in New
Hampshire very
generous uh I suggest that the
uh change of the chable gaming from a
small mom and pop C operation to a large
Casino would um be appropriate to look
at a different license fee and that's
what my bill
does the license fees for uh facilities
in Massachusetts are $85 million or
perhaps $25 million my bill says how
about $10 million free your Casino
license instead of
$250 well can The Operators afford this
we had testimony yesterday from the
Lottery Commission on how well the ATR
machines are doing and they're doing
quite
well uh the testimony was if my notes
are correct cor was that the average HR
machine would take in
$239 per
day and that trend is likely to go
upward to as much as 400 bucks a
day well let's say the machine takes in
$239 a day and you have a large casino
with a th000 slot
$239,000 per day
or if you analyze that that's $87
million per year in Gross slot revenue
for each
Casino so of that money it's uh under
the current split it's pretty generous
to the
operator the uh facility May generate
$87
million in slot revenue and they get to
keep 75% of that
million the 25% they don't keep gets
split between the Lottery Commission and
charity that hasn't
changed so the operator takes in $87
million they keep 75% so they wind up
with $65 million of gross
revenue now those of us you know with a
business background say what's the cost
of goods
here well your cost of goods is the
Box you buy a
robot you feed the robot
electricity and you open up the back
money 75% gross
margins so I suggest that a operator
with that kind of gross
margin uh can certainly afford a $10
million license fee per year for this
Enterprise now you can ask maybe
operators might be smaller another all
not all operators will have a $10
million uh exposure for the amount of
machines they have they may only have a
smaller number so I think it's
reasonable to say we can look at a a
sliding scale on this which would be $10
million for a th000 machines and then
slide down to you
know uh very modest amount for one or
two machines and that's certainly a
reasonable alternative to my proposal
and I'd asked the committee to consider
a sliding scale as well as a fixed fee
questions thank you representative
Southworth GNA call on you first thank
you and uh thank you for taking my
question um I was thinking at the very
beginning about the um cut off at a
thousand um I in your conclusion you
mentioned a sliding scale but there's
nothing about a sliding scale in the
bill are you thinking there should be an
amendment and I'm thinking two things
the words but also do you think the bill
should actually have the scale or leave
that to rules for someone yeah um I'm
just starting to deal with the immediate
problem facing the city of Nashville
with two very large casinos having over
1,000 slot machines and let's deal with
that
quickly but long term I fully support a
sliding scale and I could certainly do a
purpose yes representative Spire thank
you Mr chairman uh the um the there I
think almost every state has some sort
of gambling or games uh the with the
states out there I see that the feed
that you'd like to do is based on the
type of game do you see that other
states do it by the game do they do it
by a percentage of their gross revenue
do you do you have any idea how it's
handled in other states yes
predominately yeah I'll defer uh
director McIntyre on the details of the
other states but my belief it's uh
there's a a fee per machine was a fee
per machine yeah some for example
licensing fees uh typically a state
would license an individual machine for
about 600
bucks
um thank you and the revenue is
Consolidated among all the machines some
machines are lucky they that day and not
lucky another day but it's the
Consolidated Revenue that the operator
number representative D
said Thank you Mr chairman I'll just be
real brief because I'm sure there there
are others I'm just curious as to how
how do we impose a $10 million tax on
operators that are already operating
that complied with all our rules rules
statutes that have
invested millions of dollars into this
effort we show up on the door knock on
the door and say all of a sudden you owe
the state of New Hampshire $10 million
how how do we enforce that and how do we
avoid the
incoming uh lawsuits and sure well the
first thing is when's the bill
effective my bill is effective January 1
of next
year there's also a three-year license
license we can determine when's the
right time to cut in such a
fee do we do it at the end of the of the
gaming cycle license
cycle okay we could we could do that
with a lot of businesses in the state
the fact remains
is people made an
investment and we're basically changing
the rules midstream does
doesn't doesn't calculate here to
me thank you for the question I would
point out that tax law changes all the
time we've changed the business taxes
constantly uh we announce the changes we
don't make them
retroactive and we could decide what's
appropriate for a tax at the time we
look at the situation at the time we
looked at the taxes for charitable
gaming was very modest it was a modest
Enterprise now we have a major
Enterprise I think it's to look at the
tax
again followup yeah just one more
followup so this is just in relation to
the machines
not okay thank you oh absolutely yeah
this is a tax on the machines this is
100% related to the historic horse race
machines and no other part of the
Enterprise representative Brier thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um I'm relatively new to uh
this committee and I'm relatively new to
uh this gaming and casinos uh but what
I'm seeing around is uh just within my
house we uh I think it's called Revo or
something there's one in there's one in
dolba I know that Rochester is talking
about putting one at the Lilac mall and
I'm I'm a little bit confused because it
it sounds like we're becoming like meain
in New Hampshire and actually having
real casinos and why are we still
calling it charitable gaming again I'm
very new to this and uh I think we're
missing out on some huge Revenue
opportunities that other states are
getting and we do have a revenue problem
right now in the state and uh I guess my
question is what is there are we is part
of this doing some sort of study to look
at like should we be changing our model
and looking at opportunities like this
yeah thank you for the question we've
had a gaming
commission uh or study on a gaming
commission uh ongoing for the past two
years representative set could comment
on
that well we just we just passed a bill
yesterday out of this
committee if I if I might just uh
because it's relative I think that if if
in fact the new
commission gets seated that there are so
many issues in relation to charitable
gaming dispersion of funds I I mean that
the list is long this this is a a
commission that probably should be a
permanent commission at some point and I
think we all on the commission have
agreed with that and there are a plenty
addressed I would just summarize say my
bills a
Band-Aid I'm dealing with the facts on
the ground today do we want to wait
another two years do we want to do
something sooner do we want to do
something never I throw that question to
committee any other questions okay
representative uh next I have Alicia
Preston
hello thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee uh my name is Alicia
Preston I'm here representing the New
Hampshire charitable gaming operators
Association and we are speaking today in
opposition to this
bill just for a little background
currently there are approximately only
2,000 historic horse racing machines in
operation in the state of New Hampshire
and they're operating across 10 separate
facilities so while this would not
affect anyone today this would
absolutely impede growth of the industry
and therefore growth of Revenue to the
state most importantly to the 800 plus
Charities a benefit from the industry
right now over the summer and the fall
has been referenced a few times here uh
charity gaming study commission looked
at this issue as well as several others
as part of this review they engaged a
third party Spectrum gaming group to
look into and conduct an analysis on the
market they came back and determined
that in the long run the maximum
saturation of these HHR machines in New
Hampshire will be approximately
6,300 beyond that the M Market could
just not sustain and any more machines
for the market that is before us the
concept that there will be more than
1,000 machines at several facilities is
simply not realistic and would not be
sustainable however if one or more
larger facilities were to support such a
big amount we believe that would only be
a great benefit to both the state and of
course to the Charities if a facility
were to be charged $10 million by going
over 999 machines they're simply not
going to go over 999 machines the
revenue differential just is not there
what does that do that limits growth to
the industry and it limits revenues to
the state and to
Charities as part of its review the
gaming study commission did look at
licensing fees for charitable gaming
operators and determin the gaming
revenues from table games and HHR more
than covered the expenses of regulation
in the state of New Hampshire and they
did discuss a tiered system for
different sizes of uh facilities and
they determined that that was
unnecessary as well historically New
Hampshire has always rejected High
licensing fees across Industries because
it's impediment to growth and we see
that in industries that have grown
developed and evolved in the state over
many many decades I'm happy to answer
any
questions thank you representative
duet thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I think I heard uh an
earlier testimony that there's a 75%
profit margin to The Operators maybe you
can break that down for us no so the 75
is um with HHR 90% of the wages are
given back to the players approximately
that means 10% is held of that 25% is
given to the state and to the Charities
what's a major factor missing in that is
these machines have a cost of upwards of
15 to 18% through the manufacturer and
the vendor so you're looking at the tax
an immediate fee not including
employment and all that of anywhere from
39 to 47% is what they're paying right
out of the
gate does that mean the machines are
leased and not sold it some are bought
some are leased but they also have to
manage the programs within it and how
the payouts are done so you can't unlike
certain other games you can't just buy
the machine and house it in your
facility okay thank
you any other
questions representative ORS thank you
Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question so is the actual operator take
about
30% of from historic horse racing no the
well no the operator take from historic
horse racing by these numbers would be
anywhere from I'm doing quick math
pardon me uh I guess 53 to
61% I'm doing quick math so they've got
25% and then an additional 15 to 18%
which I guess would be 37% to 40 oh got
it okay the way yes now I got it my
sorry for
confusing okay seeing no more questions
thank
you and
lottery good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee Charlie
McIntyre Lottery Commission and with me
our compliance officer kolia Royal uh
one of the things you wanted to note for
the members of the committee is I
believe we were asked to do a fiscal
note and we submitted one
bill
I yeah I do not have any piscal notes
but I can explain to you in short order
essentially we characterize the revenue
is is essentially zero only because the
size of the rooms in question are not
going to be that much larger than a
thousand machines and the cost to go
from a, one up would be prohibitive to
any room and so if you're if that the
dividing line it would be likely they
would just have
995 which would candidly be a nightmare
for us because at any point in time one
to two% of the machines are out of order
being moved being replaced and so it's a
it would be a logistical difficulty but
I I would
imagine because that's funny large is in
context so everyone thinks I'm tall but
my son is four inches taller than I am
and so to him I am not tall um similarly
there are more machines in Twin Rivers
times two than there are in the entirey
of the state all rooms combined so
there's no technically large
Casino boxwoods has I think 5,000
machines in it mohagen sun probably has
four and so that's a large Casino in our
estimation so a thousand is not we
consider large there isn't it would be
the smallest one in Massachusetts I
think Springfield has 2,000 or 1500 I
think plane has 1250 Encore has over
3,000 and so those are larger facilities
and so for us a th000 would not be a
large operation anyway and I'm happy I
don't want to take more too much of your
time but I'm here to answer any
questions Co and I here to answer any
questions you folks have regarding
anything representative Southworth thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question would you have a different
analysis if there were some kind of
chart about a tiered system
I mean certainly the the impact of what
you assess is a policy decision for you
folks not us but there's really three
levers to pull when you're talking about
citing a gaming facility there's how
much a license fee you make them pay
what you make them pay as a going
concern and then what you make them do
to build it in the first place and I'll
give you an example uh the Cino in
Massachusetts in Encore in Boston
upfront was an $85 million license fee
they then were required to build a $2.4
billion facility for which they had to
pay the tax rate of the machines is 25%
and so those are the three economic
levers as a state you make them do or
not do and so um but that's a long way
of saying decisions regarding the
percentages are up to you folks I have
they're representative thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
good to see again so uh the one line
here that the New Hampshire HHR license
fee is
$250 I mean in in just from all the
numbers here you know from that to 10
million whatever but does that seem
artificially low to me I mean is there a
number that would actually help the
exercise it's an academic exercise it's
um it's obviously historic it's not
relates to what exists now it's what was
before I think a a game operator
employer license I think it's $
850 it's $850 that's our most expensive
license and it's you know a Minimus
given the numbers we're talking about
follow follow thank you for that so what
about the just some of the discussion
about the bigger bigger Casino operators
buying up the small Mom and Pops and you
mentioned Twin River so this is this a
problem in the state or not
you know I'm allowed to change my mind
originally I thought it would be a
problem to have the very large operators
come in and take ownership of these
things and in the last three years I've
completely done a 180 and the largest
most professional operators are the ones
who are doing it the tightest they're
the ones who literally you can't have a
speeding ticket and work for some of
these operators and so um I have it
completely turned around in terms of my
opinion my fear was the large operators
coming in and making these large
facilities and not caring about our
state and our communities and I've been
turned around on that thank
you uh yes Ros Malloy thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question do the
machines in uh New
Hampshire uh reap uh as like any machine
anywhere in the United States is there a
do we have
a are these all standard machines that
work the same system
everywhere so um the short answer is yes
and no so I don't want to sound like a
lawyer unfortunately thank you you're
talking to two of them um the physical
box is the same the communications
method to the machine is the same
there's surveillance equipment that
governs all every machine is under
camera all times in operation the same
the amount of cash flow that comes in
and out and the tracking of that is the
same all the internal controls are the
same anti money laundering principles
are the same it's the content inside the
box that gets
displayed and more importantly the back
office math that's different because it
relates to pools in terms of horse
racing which is what's makes it historic
horse racing versus a true classic video
Lottery terminal which you would also
characterize as a slot machine because
the players are playing in theory
against each other versus you're playing
directly Against the Machine which is
more popular with the players that's a a
guy could really geek out if you want
but I figure that's a good
answer representa duet thank you Mr
chairman we're at present in a
legislative moratorium for expansion
right now and we made that legislative
um I guess I can't ask you your opinion
on this but can you tell me when that
moratorium is up on
HHR it's my understanding was seven
years from last July 1st for the
moratorium and can the moratorium was
passed I believe with pretty bipartisan
support in the belief that we should
sort of build this out see where it gets
and then make a decision which is the
reason the Z representative the
commission is for 10 years uh and as a
member of it I believe still um it's
it's a long-term look at this only
because like the Nash is opening next
month we don't know like we're there
tomorrow but we don't know what the
impact that's going to have in the
community long-term shortterm we'll
visit it and we'll we'll follow up and
we'll see but it's we're still building
it follow up and would you agree with me
it's my belief that the commission if
establish this should be an issue that
is directly taken up with that
commission also yes and as you were
alluded to earlier representative quite
accurately there are a number of issues
that need to be taken up by thank
you yes represent elberger thank you Mr
chair thank you for my question I don't
know a way to put this without sounding
a little bit crude but are there any
casino operators in the state that are
struggling
financially um thank you for the
question representative it's nice not to
see you through a speaker too that's
from last time oh
yes
um not that we're aware not that we're
aware um and to be candid there are a
number of coy division runs Audits and
investigation and those are sort of priv
Ed to a large extent I'm not asking for
of course and so yeah no one we're aware
is having difficulty financially okay
thank
you all right seeing no more questions
thank you very
much and I will is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on HB
540 see none I'll close the public
hearing on HP
540 back concludes
today's public hearings and um watch the
calendar for uh next so as I said next
week uh we most likely will meet Monday
Tuesday Wednesday the following week
Monday Tuesday Wednesday and uh watch
the calendar for next week at least but
I want to at least get that out there so
for scheduling
purposes uh you know what to